one of the things i really found
striking about tammy is like she did a
very detailed picture of my daughter's
surgical wound and that's not an easy
thing to look at right because you don't
want to look at that but that also ties
in with the ideas we've been discussing
about well i think that's the question
yes the mystery of the crucifixion right
all these images that we have like the
beauty of christ wounds all these things
which sounds so
completely uh pathological yeah to many
people if you can understand them
properly you can understand that you
have to gaze on that which most
threatens you
[Music]
so hello everyone i'm pleased here
pleased today
um to have with me
jonathan pagio and john verveicky
people that most of you many of you not
all of you will be familiar with
um
i s i've been working on a new book uh
entitled we who wrestle with god and
it's been influenced by
jonathan's ideas and
john's ideas and
i developed an argument
in part as a consequence of the public
lectures i've been doing for the last
three months trying to push my ideas
farther and
i i
put forward a set of propositions that
i'm basing one of the book chapters on
i wrote it as an outline and then i
think it's solid i've been testing it
when i've been speaking at universities
as well to diverse audiences of
specialists to see if they'll object to
it because i think it's actually quite
radical and i sent this group of
propositions or this list of
propositions to jonathan and john a
month ago about and we've been going
back and forth
and i thought
i heard jonathan was coming to town to
do a talk with john and i thought hey
that's a good opportunity we could get
together and walk through these
propositions because i'd like to see if
if they're solid because
if they're solid well that's good and if
they're not i'd like to find out and so
we're going to do this a little
different
this is going to be a little different
than many of the conversations i've had
because it'll have a bit more structure
and i i want to read the propositions
there's i think about 15 of them
and i want
jonathan and and john to
comment on them to
tell me where they agree to tell me
where they disagree tell me what they
don't understand and to see if i can
well learn something as a consequence
that's kind of the hope and
so we'll start with this first
proposition
to see the world
we must
must
prioritize
our perceptions
so
john i'll ask you about that first
because that's
a particular
i believe a particular focus of yours i
don't think that's an exaggeration no
it's not that's that's that's the core
of my work
and so
the main
way i would respond to this is i would
say
i think the work that's coming out from
artificial intelligence and the work
that's coming out from attention lines
up with this very well
um i don't have any significant
disagreement with that proposition
and the must part of it as well
because
so the must i took well let me tell you
how i took the nest yeah and i took it
as what's called constitutive necessity
i took it to be if you are going to be a
cognitive agent
then you must do this i didn't take it
to be a metaphysical necessity i took it
to be that kind of constitutional
necessity i think it's useful to start
with what you describe as constituent
necessities before you move into the
realm of metaphysics exactly i think
that's a good way to argue you should
right and so
i think
and i'm not going to
uh recapitulate all these arguments but
a lot of work i think zeroes in on the
idea
that the core of what makes us
intelligent
and the thing that we're finding
difficult to give to machines to make
them artificially general intelligence
is a process i call relevance
realization which is exactly i think
lines up with this very well the amount
of information available to you in the
world is astronomically vast all the
things you could pay attention to
the amount of information in your
long-term memory especially if you think
of all the ways it could be combined is
also astronomically vast
the number of options of potential lines
of behavior i could move this finger
this finger i could move them i could
lift like
the ways i could move around that's
combinatorial explosion all of it all of
it and then right and then you can also
consider you know
all of the options uh of different
of potential worlds you might want to
consider trying to produce or moving
into right and so the point is in many
different dimensions we face
combinatorial explosion and what's
um what you can't do
and this is where it lines up with the
must because we're finite beings yes
with finite resources and finite time
you can't check all of that information
so you can't go and say no that's not
relevant that's not relevant that memory
is not relevant that will take like the
the rest of the history of the universe
right right right
so so we don't know how we do it in fact
because of that in part well i mean i
think
i think there's getting some clues
towards it um but we can talk about that
later okay right so the must and the
prioritization on the perception side
you're fine with it has to be it has to
be and here but here's the tricky thing
um which is
um
the fact that we can't check it means
and this sounds almost like a zen cohen
is the prioritization is odd uh when you
say it sort of
like prima facie yeah because it means
we intelligently ignore
most of the information right so the
prioritizing the what i want to put yeah
that's a good code of sale so you're
saying that
you don't want to misinterpret the
necessity for prioritization as are as
something like
the necessity or our ability to make a
numbered list of exactly the number of
possibilities that lay out in front of
us because that's actually impossible
right so so that isn't how we do it
however we do it isn't that exactly so
when you when when if if if you're okay
with that reading and it sounds like you
are prioritization doesn't mean what we
normally mean by prioritization where we
set things out explicit and focal and
then choose right right it's implicit
it's implicit and it's self-organizing
and our ability to think and it's
unconscious yes emerges out of it we
we can influence it top down but because
it is an absolute requirement for our
cognition i would argue that our ability
to do anything that we do consciously is
ultimately dependent on it and
presupposes it right okay fine so that's
good jonathan
the only thing that i would add is
you have to phrase it in a certain way
there's no you have to have a sentence
but there's a sense in with perception
when we say we must prioritize our
perceptions i i think the best way to
understand is that perception is already
prioritization is
[Music]
an act of
implicit prioritization right and to use
the word implicit would be a good idea
so to avoid the idea that we are
consciously doing it but that in order
to even perceive the world there already
has to be
a given hierarchy that is that is making
you able to focus on anything because
yeah or else we yeah or else we would be
lost in a in a way as you know a sea of
infinite details okay so i think that's
a good cortisol and so we could also
make a little technical case here
quickly
so part of the problem that john john
referred to is that
in some sense it's the problem of the
finite confronting the infinite and so
we could make a neurological argument
for that so for example when you move
your eyes around or when they move
around as a consequence of being
directed by unconscious
structures of prioritization because
that happens all the time
you move your eyes around because you
want to direct the high resolution part
of your visual system to whatever you're
attending to
that's the fovea and the fovea is a very
small part of your retina and
it's a very high resolution part so each
cell in the fovea is connected at the
level of the primary visual cortex to 10
000 cells and then each of those have 10
000 connections and so if your whole
vision was foveal in its
um in its resolution you'd have to have
a skull like an alien to contain that
much brain and so
so so and that's a real indication of
that finitude right is that you do have
limited cognitive resources and limited
means
practically and physically limited but
it also means metabolically limited the
the cost of running your brain is
already extremely high and
and so you're going to shepherd your
available
attentional resources because they are
finite and and they're finite in no
small part because they are technically
metabolically
costly that all seems
okay
so i would add one thing to that which
is i would put an emphasis on how this
process has to be self-organizing
because we want to avoid
a perennial problem which you and i know
shows up in psychology which is to posit
the internal homocylous yeah that
actually doesn't explain the problem but
just shifts it the central executive is
an example of this etc so we don't we we
don't want to say that there's someone
that's doing the prioritization because
that someone is just as mysterious right
and is facing the very problem that
we're trying to explain so yeah right
the process has to be dynamically so far
well one of the ways i've
realized
how that problem works is in an attempt
to solve the mind-body problem because
you can't solve the mind-body problem
but you can say let's say you're you
want to uh explore an idea and you
decide to do that by writing an essay so
then you sit down in front of the
computer which is not an idea it's
actually that you're sitting and then
you move your fingers on the keyboard
and so there's a hierarchy of
transformation from mind which might be
the abstract intent to body and so and
so the the spirit hits the body in the
finger movements and then the spirit
disappears in some sense under the
finger movements because you can move
your fingers voluntarily but you have no
idea what muscles you're moving to do
that and you can't control the cells or
anything like that oh i did that with my
students in the lecture this morning i
was talking about uh this very fact that
i said uh put up your finger
okay bend your finger
what do you do to bend your finger right
exactly exactly so interesting
it's so interesting that you have that
level of consciousness at that level of
detail which is pretty detailed but no
more than that yes yes yeah so that's a
mystery man that that that that
localization of consciousness
between the body and part of the spirit
there's like a there's like a what would
you call it a
there's a bandwidth there's a bandwidth
of resolution for consciousness yes and
why that been see the social
psychologists who studied language sort
of caught on to this because one of the
things they realized was that
short words first of all short words
tend to be old words
so because as language develops words
that are used a lot get more efficient
but the short words also map
extraordinarily well onto the
self-evident level of perception and so
for example a short word is cat because
a cat presents itself
for some reason to our perception the
species cat doesn't and the
the fur of the cat in some sense doesn't
it's the cat yes and and you can see
that
primary object level recognition
basically basic level that's really
rushed yes yes yes yes and so you see
that with babies because they get
doggy pretty damn fast and that beca
that's because the language maps on to
the primary domain of perception that
basic level perception quite nicely and
that is associated with something like
the natural
bandwidth of consciousness yeah i i
would i would say that that lines up
with if you russia's explanation
is you know you're getting the best
trade-off between differences between
category and similarities within
categories right and then the question
is what does best trade-off mean exactly
and that's and and for me that's that's
what that would that be a little bit of
um
i i guess a nuance i'd want to put on to
uh the prioritization because the
prioritization sounds
very but sort of like an imposition
whereas i think what we're talking about
is something more like what morrow ponte
talked about when he talked about
optimal gripping
right so what
what's that what's the correct
you know distance to look at this well
it depends because if i zoom in i lose
the gestalt if i zoom out i lose the
detail depends on what you want to do
exactly well that's well that's it
that's why i'm kind of attracted to
pragmatism it's like well to some degree
our theories of truth need to be
embedded in the practicalities of action
and so
is that a grippable object that i can
drink from well i want my perception to
match that problem
yeah but it doesn't i think that it if
you understand that the prioritization
let's say that you have heaven and earth
i'm going to use sorry these mythical
categories but so you have these fines
you have heaven and earth and that
it's the way in which heaven meets earth
is a is a mutual relationship right we
always see it as a relationship of
lovers you could say but it's not the
prioritization isn't just about an
imposition from above but it's about the
manner in which that which is above
let's say the
the hierarchy is able to encounter the
potential in which it's we were talking
about that last night so jonathan made
this funny joke last night we were
talking about sam harris and sam harris
has this
uh line of argumentation
where and he used this on me where i
interpreted a biblical story and then he
interpreted a recipe yes and he said
well look at all the interpretations and
that is a problem of
of semiotic drift yes exactly well it's
also a problem of this horizon of
infinite possibility there are multiple
interpretive schemes so jonathan said
he'd like to do a video where he shows
that a recipe is actually necessarily
embedded inside a mythological framework
and we started to talk about that
because imagine well the re the recipe
implies
that you need to make an edible meal
that you want to make an edible meal
that you're going to serve it to family
and friends that that's part of a kind
of communion that you think that's a
good thing that's worth spending time on
that serves your family and friends
that's maybe nested in something like an
ethic of service to the community like
there's a whole there's a whole network
of purpose i would add more to that
there's all kinds of implicit
assumptions that i can capture in a
sequence of propositions procedural
skills that are not completely
capturable in words and that those
procedures and skills can also map on to
the particular virtues and skill
you know that that people are bringing
together like
it's like
most things can't be solved by a recipe
right right and yet so a recipe is a
significant cognitive cultural
achievement and we don't recognize like
and and and
we we we we tend to over generalize the
things we think for which we can provide
recipes this is one of them
that's an algorithm issue yes exactly
exactly and so there's lots yeah even in
the recipe itself you will notice that
the way in which we name things and the
way in which we order things will be
related to a normal prioritization
hierarchy prioritization but if you're
making chicken you'll have the chicken
and then you'll have the spices and
you'll understand that these elements
that i'm adding are spices and that
they're they're let's say something like
a marginalia that i'm adding to the
central meal it's actually the very it's
like it's the pattern of a church
actually you know where you have a
movement towards the central identity
that we understand and then we have
the way in which it's complemented
through other things and so even the
actual recipe itself is like a little
cup and also the judgment you use is
like well how much spice well the answer
is well what function is the spice going
to serve and you say well i want to let
add a little zest and interest to my
cooking and so then you have a
philosophy of zest and interest that's
associated with that because just
predictable chicken isn't good enough
and maybe you want to put a little more
spice on because you want to uh what
would you say you want to uh challenge
your guests a little bit in an
interesting way and you're thinking this
all through and for the same reason
you'd wear funny socks or a tie that has
just a little bit too much on it you
know well
i mean that's actually the future of
general problem solving like you when
people are solving a problem especially
if they might get the wrong frame
moderately distracting you from the
central concern is an optimal way yeah
exactly you need to do that so what i'm
hearing both of you say is the
prioritization is really a
multi-dimensional optimal gripping
that's right that's right
okay well then that we can also expand
on that to some degree because
multi-dimensional and optimal
brings a lot of other concerns into it
so imagine that one of the principles
and and can't
move towards this with his theory of
universal ethic in some sense although i
think it
you know hesitate to criticize can't be
but
i i think that there's a deeper
explanation for what he observes is well
how should i treat you
well that's a complex question but one
of the constraints is well
what if we meet a hundred times
so we're going to establish an actual
relationship so however i conduct myself
in the present moment
has to
be in accordance with the value
hierarchy that takes into account the
desirability of our mutual
interrelationship into the future and
that produces a very serious series of i
would say
often intrinsic constraints so i can't
be too insulting i can't be too
unwelcoming i have to offer you
something approximating a true
reciprocity for the thing not to
degenerate
and so and all of that and i would say
that also governs how you cook for
someone if you actually want to make
friends so it's like treat other people
as you would like them to treat you and
it's pretty funny that that's the
intrinsic ethic in a recipe and so
that's a good that's that's such a funny
argument
we'll get right back to jonathan pajot
and john varvakey in just a moment first
we'd like to tell you about elysium
health founded by dr leonard garente a
renowned mit researcher and 30-year
student of the science of aging elysium
health is on a mission to translate
critical scientific advancements in
aging research into accessible health
products and technologies their flagship
product basis replenishes youthful
levels of nad plus activating what
scientists call our longevity genes to
promote healthy aging and keep you
feeling younger longer many customers
report benefits such as sustained
maintained energy levels less general
tiredness and fatigue more satisfying
workouts and support in recovery from
workouts healthy skin and general health
and wellness matter elysium's brain
aging supplement was developed in
partnership with the university of
oxford mata does what no other product
does it slows the shrinking of our
brains for most of us brain shrinkage
begins in our 30s and impacts memory
learning and even physical activity
lifestyle factors such as alcohol
consumption smoking and poor sleep
habits accelerate this process matter is
patented and clinically proven to slow
the age-related loss in the brain's
memory centers by an average of 86
many matter customers have reported
improvements in memory and cognition go
to explorematter.com jordan and enter
code jbp10 at checkout to save 10 off
matter prepaid subscriptions as well as
other elysium health supplements
okay so let's move to the second um
presupposition
to act in the world so it's kind of a or
the first or something equivalent to act
in the world we must prioritize our
actions i don't think we probably have
to cover that right because it's
perception is an action already because
you have to move your eyes and orient
your head and optimal gripping is an
action yes exactly so i think that goes
with it yeah okay so so we'll leave that
we'll okay now this is the next this is
a nice switch i think any system of
priorities
is a structure of values and then i
sneak something in an ethic so i'm kind
of defining ethic as a
something approximating perhaps an
internally cons it's like a game it's an
internally consistent
hierarchy of value but it's also it's
going to have to be iterable in the
sense that we already discussed so
that's kind of what i'm defining an
ethic as and then you could also think
of it as something that's embodied so
when you're watching someone on a screen
in a movie say a character they embody
an ethic that's what makes them
interesting it's a whole
structure of value and they're acting it
out and it's a system of priorities of
perception and action
and that's a value structure the reason
it's a value structure is because well
what's the difference between
prioritization and value you you
prioritize what you value and so i think
the difficulty i have is if you use the
word ethic because the word ethic is so
charged with uh morality and also to the
way that we're supposed to act between
each other then i think it it can be a
little bit misleading because value is
great why is good it seems to well i
think good is fine that is the good in
the sense that there's also a good glass
which has no moral rearing at all
there's a there's a good way to walk
down the hall which is not a moral
question there's a you know the good way
to fish but these are not ethical
maybe they are maybe yeah maybe but i i
think that that's maybe the little place
where i would wonder about it yeah so
that's a terminological problem in some
sense right well it is i don't know what
do you think that it seems as the word
ethic seems to imply interpersonal
relationships yeah the word ethic has
been reduced to the moral interaction
ethical yes yes whereas uh typically
philosoph philosophers will use the term
normativity to be a much more general
term for cover for the idea that there's
a governing principle for your behavior
um
okay so i i'll have to make sure i
clarify that when i read about this but
i was also thinking about you know
common fictional tropes in in popular
culture so
if you're watching a mafia movie one of
the things that's interesting about a
mafia criminal as opposed to just your
ordinary criminal is
that he's not entirely chaotic
right he abides by the mafia code so
he's loyal to his
certain code yeah he's loyal to a code
so it makes him a quasi-ethic actor and
i would say well the mafia character
does embody an ethic and i'm kind of
struggling for a word that isn't ethic
you might disagree with the other but i
think it's because i mean i think you
can actually take this a lot further
than than just a mafia person i think
there's a way that you can be a good
mass murderer
that in the sense that you can you can
you have discovered the hierarchy of
values things you need to value in order
to become a good mass murderer and now
you're engaging in them towards that
hierarchy of values they're like you can
say like they are satanic hierarchies
like this
for example we're doing exactly that and
most of the mass shooters
there's a contest going on they know
about each other they're often in fact
one of them one kid who was planning to
do this wrote me like really six months
ago he had a 50-page manifesto ready and
the weapons and he watched this this
youtube video discussion i did with
warren farrell and where we touched on
this issue and he decided that there was
seriously something wrong with him and
that he should get some help and not do
this but he was in contact with one of
the people who went out and shot up a
high school they'd been contacted online
so he was like that far away from it
yeah but so so there is this
it's not a com
you can have a chaotic criminal who's
completely unpredictable but then you
don't have much of a plot right he's not
an interesting character he's gonna get
caught really fast well there's that too
right the far more interesting ones have
a they haven't well i'd say they have an
ethic now it's not an ethical ethic
right so that's why the word ethic is
difficult because you could say that
ultimately what you're going to what's
going to happen is that there will be a
hierarchy of value systems yeah that
will be more related to the good in the
in the classical sense that is plato
yeah exactly exactly exactly and this is
plato's argument that nobody willingly
does evil everybody does what they
conceive to be a good in some fashion
yeah you see that in dante you see the
same his whole movement he even talks
about how the people in hell everybody
is there because of i'm reading the
divine comedy right that's wonderful
yeah it's great everybody who is there
is there because of love
for a good even though even if they love
the good too much or they're mistaken
about let's say the actual ultimate
value of that good everybody moves
towards a good even if you're doing
something which is completely
reprehensible yeah the proposal that sin
is actually failing to love wisely
yeah i have i have some problem with
that viewpoint because i think i think
that happens i do think that happens and
i think many of the you know i've talked
to people like my friend greg hurwitz
who writes thrillers and he crafts
pretty evil characters and we've talked
about that a lot
an evil character with an ethic so like
a misplaced love is is a very
interesting character but then there's
the other sorts of characters that are
more cane-like because cain
i his spirit that the spirit that's
expressed in that story
his
he isn't aiming at something that's good
he's aiming at
getting away with lying to god he's
aiming at getting away with making
insufficient sacrifices he's aiming at
getting away
eventually with murder it's not a
perversion of the good and i think that
we underestimate the problem of evil if
we assume that it's merely a consequence
of worshiping false idols say because
the idol can be so it's like i talked to
you last night about the reports that
michelle foucault raped boys in
graveyards it's like
okay
he argued even formally culturally to
abolish or at least radically reduce the
age of consent and a lot of
intellectuals went along with them and
maybe you can have a discussion about
that and what the age of consent could
be and maybe you can't there's room for
differences in opinion there but
when your pedophilia involves graveyard
sex
then that's not a misplaced good
like that's that's that's but why not
jordan why why isn't that
pleasure is a good
right and and well it's so specific
you know why the graveyard like there's
something so dark i don't think there's
i think that's a place that's so dark
that you can't go there without knowing
that it's dark and i do think that i
really do believe and i you know i've
done my best to study the thought of
people who've done truly reprehensible
things is that there's a level of
reprehensibility where
you are going there to cause the most
trouble you can and i don't see
if there's any good left in that it's
such a time i'm really gonna be like i'm
really gonna be the devil's advocate
here knowing that there are some that do
it better than others and some of them
don't do it as well even recognizing
that the good that they're aiming
towards is is not really
transcendentally their memory has to be
working their problems right that is
that they that it's like if i yeah so
they're still driven by a coherent
spirit well that's what i think the
spirit of lucifer and this and the
spirit of girth is mephistopheles that's
that's and the spirit of cain that's a
description of that ethic it does you
know it is it is a coherent personality
and that's why there's so much well and
milton as well it's it's there's been an
attempt to delineate the ethic of evil
and and it's not merely chaotic and the
reason one of the reasons why it's
important and maybe it's hard to to to
see that right away but one of the
reasons why it's important is i find it
important to formulate it this way the
way that dante formulated it or that
plato formulated it is that if you don't
go in this direction you end up with a
dualism and then they end up acting as
like two opposites whereas there's the
the more platonic way of setting it up
what ends up happening is that
the evil always ends up just being a
perversion of the good right parasitic
is it always parasitic and so what what
it does is that it makes the good truly
good and makes it all pervasive and a
way in which it can actually fill up the
entire
cosmos you know the this right so that
even in the death of hell the love of
god is there like you see that in a lot
of the christian mystics that there is
no place that is okay so
let me ask you about that on the grounds
of christian theology so and i'm i'm
probably going to mangle this and so
correct me well there's an idea that in
the book of revelation that christ is
the eternal judge but that he's also a
judge who comes back at the end of days
and
separates the wheat from the chaff the
damned from the saved and the
implication in that
book is that
many are called but few are chosen the
judgment's pretty damn harsh and
most
most what most spirits are damned most
people are damned and then is that
eternal or is there a reconciliation and
so i don't know the answer to that so
the the christians
the best way
this is gonna
this is the type of thing that could
actually get me in trouble but like the
best way to formulate it i think that
we're seeing in the orthodox tradition
right now is to say that we live in the
hope of
a final restoration but that we cannot
universal redemption but we cannot posit
it because you like you said there are
seems to be there seem to be two
traditions in the christian world
there's a tradition of final restoration
which you find in revelation as well by
the way because it says the last thing
to to die is death itself right there's
the sensor where death is thrown into
the fire and so the last what exactly is
that referring to the sense in which the
heavenly jerusalem descends and embod
fills up the entire world so you have
these images and then you also have an
image of evil being completely let's say
cast off and those two kind of exist in
uh
well it's i was thinking this about this
the other day when i was thinking about
making a video address to
do the islamic world as preposterous as
that might sound
because one of the things you want to do
when you're talking to people is you
want to distinguish between
them as of intrinsic value and
redeemable in some final sense just as
you are and ideas that might be
possessing them that have either this
misplaced good element to them or this
vengeful element and so
you know you don't want to throw to use
a horrible cliche you don't want to
throw the baby out with the bath water
and so maybe the separation of the wheat
from the chaff is a spiritual
discrimination that doesn't throw out
the entire being along with the judgment
you understand it fractally then i think
that that makes sense
if you read like for example c.s lewis
is a great example of someone who kind
of was going in that direction was
hinting at some things he talked about
how like the this notion that the key to
hell is hell is locked from the inside
right
no matter
even like i think cs lewis said like
even in the depth of either the death of
hell if satan wanted to repent there's
well that's what milton's but that's not
but that's not it's like it's not
happening because that's the role that's
in the story this is the character that
helping you understand this part of the
cosmos that or the part of the way that
the world is laying itself out and you
see that in in in some of the syrian
fathers for example said from the syrian
he he says things like that where he
says as the the fire in hell is the same
fire that was at pentecost the fire in
hell is the love of god
and it's and it's and it's it's only
that to the extent that you reach your
distance to be transformed yeah and you
hold on to your let's say parasitic good
that is what the fire of hell is well
right well part of that is is that as
you become more divorced from let's say
what constitutes a sustainable and valid
good the farther you get away from that
whether it's merely by pursuing a
misplaced good or it's by conscious
design the more that elevates itself up
as the harshest possible judge that will
do the most damage to your current ethic
and then destabilize your whole
perceptions and so
that's so interesting because as you
deviate
speaking spiritually as you deviate from
god he becomes more tyrannical in some
sense to you and more judgmental and
it's also partly because this is why the
catholic uh
idea of confession is isn't what's often
pilloried because you know people laugh
well you're a catholic you can sin your
whole life and on your deathbed you can
repent but yeah but you have to
face the magnitude of everything you did
wrong so
repentance isn't just well i'm sorry
it's like you're actually sorry and if
you've stacked up a whole lifetimes of a
lifetime of sins what makes you think
that you're going to have the moral
wherewithal on your deathbed to confront
that without anything
well it's just absolute existential
terror yes so it's there's no easy out
from that so
so uh
i mean
i thought the discussion was
um important um and what you just said
jordan is important i i i i for i for
one would not want immortality because
when i look back at the foolishness and
and the vices of my past um uh
yeah it it it it it's hard it's and so
um people who think they could just sort
of sin in mouth uh i don't mouth of
repentance i don't think that's well
they also think they can in some sense
pull one over god yeah but or we could
we'll abide by this rule that we'll
never use religious language when we can
use any other kind of language no no no
but i know i know you weren't objecting
to that but i think it's a good
principle but i'm happy i'm happy to
talk about it um uh i i'll but i don't
um
well let me say
there's there's something underneath the
religious discussion that is sort of a
central concern to me at this point
um
and i'll invoke kant um
part writes the three critiques
right the critique of pure reason
practical reason judgment right and the
and and habermas makes a great point of
this i'm coming to it i'm coming to the
point which is
we don't see
since caught we don't have an integrated
normativity
we have three autonomous spheres of
around the true the epistemic the good
and the beautiful and what what what
kant did and one of the problems of
modernity and this is habermas's point
is he made a very strong case for the
autonomy of each right beauty is beauty
so that's partly why you objected in the
way you did when you emailed me back
because you i was talking about an ethic
that would unite and you said well it's
differentiated true beautiful and good
right my response to that would be
something like well whatever god is
fundamentally ineffable so we'll make
that we'll make that clear to begin with
but
i would say that
one way of thinking about the way we
think about god is that god is what's
common to the good the true and the
beautiful so this gets us into the the
the discussion that i think is for me
sort of the deepest levels of the
phenomenology
and the cognition which is i mean that
jonathan would know this is the
classical doctrine the classical way of
putting this is the convertible of the
tren the the transcendentals are
convertible into each other so somehow
the true and the good and and the
beautiful are one but not mathematical
identity this is really important it's
not right you can right and so
and it you know aquinas wrestles with
this mac i've been reading maximus by
the way i think you see a reflection of
that in the idea of the trinity too well
of course right and and and and
so the issue there is
um
and i've been reading dc schindler on
the catholicity of reason and he talks
about this he gets it from balthazar he
talks about the primacy of
um the primacy of beauty the centrality
of goodness and the ultimacy of truth
that they they are superlative but in
different ways uh so what he means by
that is there's a primacy to beauty and
and this is a classic platonic argument
if you don't have beauty all the other
normativities are not available to you
right
so why write that's not so like i i i
wrote a chapter in my last book on the
necessity of beauty but but i don't
understand why that why prime why
primary
because and what does that say about our
perception that it's primary itself
right because you don't have to think
about it is that part of it is that you
apprehend it i i don't understand well a
way of thinking about it is uh scary
wrote a really beautiful book called
beauty and how it prepares us for truth
and justice and the idea so let let's
let's do let's take something that's
that's very culturally relevant and
something i've been talking about so we
we are we are immersed in what recur
called a hermeneutics of suspicion the
hermeneutics of suspicion is that
appearances are always distorting
distracting deceiving us from reality
that's the human expression and the
moment of truth is when you reveal
the hidden cabal the conspiracy right
this is the hermeneutics of suspicion
and it's you know and and recur's point
is we got this that's what freud does
it's the uncovering
that's right here's what's really going
on the deconstruction is here's what's
real exactly exactly everywhere now
right exactly okay yeah yeah now here's
marlo ponti's point about this right his
point is but wait
the hermeneutics uh of of that the
ruminants of suspicion is always
dependent on this if i say that's unreal
oh look i do that because i say that's
real realization is always a comparative
judgment this is his point
so and so does he accept the notion that
there is something because one of the
things you see in the post-modern types
and i was looking at richard rorty the
work the other day and he seems to buy
the post-modern idea that everything is
just a network of linguistic
representation and that there is no real
beyond that that's that's dylan's
critique of that being semillogical
reductionism all you do is transfer all
the markers of reality onto properties
of the text and then you you you prevent
the text from being subject to the very
criticisms you're making of reality yeah
well that that that seems credible to me
okay so so so it was pop merlot party
accepts the reality of beauty
exactly because think about think about
what this means if the hermeneutics of
suspicion is
right that appearances distract us
deceive us
there has to be something under that
right and beauty is when appearances
disclose reality right
yeah
that's the that's what i mean that's
what i believe that that's the artist i
mean that's the artist take or that's
the liturgical take or it's the
the beauty of an of a church or the
beauty of an icon or the it's it's the
notion that
that that god or ultimate reality or
however you want to phrase it is
disclosing itself to us and that appears
to us
as the connection between
that which we encounter these these
patterned beings that we encounter and
what they reveal to us about the other
transcendentals
well when i wrote this chapter which is
my favorite chapter in both books it's
try to make one room in your house as
beautiful as possible and so it's this
sort of step behind well order your room
first so that it's just not cluttered
and and idiotic and and running at
counter purposes to whatever your
purposes are reflection of your internal
chaos get it orderly but that's not good
enough the next thing is see if you can
make a relationship with beauty which is
really it's it's really uh people are
afraid of that eh because i've watched
people try to buy art and they're
terrified of buying art and the reason
is is because
their choice puts their taste on display
and if their taste is
undeveloped then their inability to
distinguish between a false appearance
and the genuine reality of beauty is
immediately revealed to people so
they're terrified of it but they're also
equally terrified of beauty so let me
tell you a story about this if you don't
mind
i i bought some russian impressionist
paintings for my father
and uh i liked them a lot uh this
particular artist
the russian impressionist style is like
the french and personal style except
it's a lot rougher the brush strokes are
thicker so it's lower resolution but
it's equally beautiful in terms of
palette and i have a variety of
paintings if you get some distance from
them they just snap into representations
so lovely and so i sent my dad like
eight of these paintings and my mom took
one look at them and she said
those are not coming out of the basement
and so and my mom is is a conservative
person so she's not high in openness
she's not that interested in ideas and
she's not and her aesthetic sense isn't
sophisticated now my mother has a lot of
lovely attributes but but and my dad and
her differ in that and so i he loved
these paintings and then he made these
frames for them and then he brought one
up
and my mom tolerated that and then he
brought another one up and then she
tolerated that and then like all eight
of them eventually made it upstairs and
then a few years later i was there and
she told me how much she loved the
paintings but it really they really set
her off and i think it was partly
because
well if you're
imagine you have
you're comfortable in your canonical
perceptions of objects in some sense and
then the impressions come along and say
you know you could look at that whole
landscape as if it was nothing but the
interplay of color and that's we forget
how radical that is i mean those
paintings caused riots in paris when
they were first showed impressionist
paintings and that's what my mother was
reacting to it's like oh my god there's
a whole different way of looking at the
world i don't want to see that and it's
an invitation to
that which is beyond the triviality of
your perceptions let's say but it's to
think that there's nothing about that
that's
worth being frightened of or challenging
you don't understand conservatives if
you don't see that so but in terms of in
terms of judy one of the things that
also that especially now you can one of
the the problems or the the way that
beauty can kind of overwhelm us is that
we feel as if if we give ourselves we we
were afraid of the
the suspicion of the hermeneutics of
suspicion we're afraid that if we we see
reality discloses itself to us and we
can see the connection between that
which is appearing to me and some
something behind it then i'm afraid that
if i jump if i make that leap then i'll
be betrayed or all that or that it will
right that it won't turn out to be real
or well sometimes sometimes it's not
like so there are there there is it is
possible to to be tricked by
by appearances and this gets you to to
hans you know saving beauty his critique
of what you see going on right now
is he he he argues if you read ancient
texts if you read platynus one of the
features they'll say about beauty is
it's striking and disturbing and
disrupting right
i want to come back to that about the
transformative aspect of truth but but
right the transformative theory of truth
but and han talks about now what we've
done right and he talks about in other
books too is we've reduced we try to
reduce the beautiful to the smooth
which is the the ease at which we can
consume something yeah like the smoother
cover of a car exactly right one pixel
resolution yes yes and and and because
because what that does is it gives you
and i'll use this word deliberately the
veneer of beauty yeah but while
protecting you from the hormones oh
that's a suspicion yeah right you see
that so what we do is and then he says
and pornography is the primary example
of that because what you do is you
remove all threat all mystery all
otherness up from the person so there's
no way they can strike you or disturb
you there's no rejection
right yes exactly and so pornography is
an example of
of the smooth completely overtaking the
beautiful and being misunderstood
as the beautiful
but
if that's if you if you gentlemen are in
agreement with it what that mean that's
my answer to why the primacy of beauty
because if you do not get that ability
to and i want to use this word
sorry please go ahead then i'll ask yeah
i i want to say through the way i'm
saying like through my glasses beyond
and by means of if we can't properly get
a moment where we can see through
appearance into reality we are locked
into solipsism and skepticism you need a
primary and if you do it if you do it
rather than it is called to you then you
are trapped right you nee you need
something that calls you from beyond the
appearances so that you can properly
align appearances to reality and you
realize that's why the prime minister is
that the ontological calling you out of
epistemology
i would argue that that's plato's
argument for what how the beauty
so when you say okay so
i i've thought thought a lot about the
relationship between love and truth and
i think love is primary and the truth is
the handmaiden of love in some sense but
but so there's a primacy there i would
say the primacy of love but you're
making an argument for the primacy of
beauty and so are they contradictory no
no no no not at all because plato's view
of love
and you have to be careful because plato
is taking the greek notion of eros and
he's trying to bend it and i think he's
trying to bend it towards what the
christians are going to eventually talk
about in agape right okay so take that
as a caveat on what i'm saying but
nevertheless what's going on right is
plato says no no no what love is is that
you are called
to beauty and let me let
let me let me just try and show you give
me a sec because there's a connection
yeah okay so a lot this will sound like
where is he out of left field but right
truth rationality
most of the cognitive biases in fact
there's a growing argument that a lot of
the cognitive biases confirmation bias
blah blah blah a lot of them are
actually
versions aspects of the my side bias
egocentrism i won't make that argument
here i think it's a good argument but
let's say even if it's only partially
true this is an important point
and spinoza got this right
this orientation
self-relevance how things are relevant
to me
right that sort of fundamental
egocentrism a fundamental way in which
you're prioritizing your perception on
the world right you can't reason your
way out of that benoza the most logical
of the philosophers says no no the only
thing that will invert the arrow of
relevance is love this is murdoch's
point love is when you recognize
something other than yourself as real
right okay so so let's okay let me ask
you about that because
i've been thinking about the idea of
being selfish yes you know well
psychopaths are selfish but they also
betray themselves yes because
psychopaths don't learn from experience
and they doom their future selves and so
i kind of wonder if the love that re
lifts you out of
this self-orientation what it does in
some sense is that it's the way you see
the world if you
see
beyond this narrow selfishness because i
don't really think there's any
difference technically in me in me
taking care of the multitude of future
selves that i will become and me
treating you properly i think it's a
great okay
i think your relationship to your future
self is ultimately an agopic
relationship and i think that's the only
way you can deal with a lot of empirical
research okay so you do you do yes
why the empirical research because i
think the empirical research shows that
like the i mentioned it in the cambridge
talk that i sent you a little bit right
what if you do this
this is one instance among many
experiments you go into a bunch of
academics at a university the people who
are supposed to be the best at taking
data and processing it you present them
with all the evidence that they should
start saving for their retirement right
now right and they won't do it you come
back six months later they'll they will
they you asked them at the time
i
is solid solid argument great evidence
yeah come back six months have they
changed not at all the behaviors
behavioral therapists know that
perfectly well right yeah but
so if you but if you do the following
you say i want you to
imagine your future self as a family
member that you love and care about
right right they will start to
save and more importantly the vividness
of that imagery predicts how well that's
so cool look you know this this program
that we worked on the future authoring
program well it's predicated on the idea
of developing
a love for your future self so so it's
an exercise is it's a real sense it's
it's like here and it's
the ethic that's underneath it although
this wasn't particularly conscious in my
mind when i built it was
knock and the door will open it's like
okay
let's play a game you get to have
what you want and need but the rule is
first of all you have to accept it and
second of all you have to specify it and
so but let's just play it as a game yeah
if you could if you could envision a
future that would justify your suffering
that's a really good way of thinking
about it justify your suffering what
would that entail and then people and
then i make it practical it's like well
what do you want for an intimate
relationship how do you want to treat
your family members what sort of job or
career like i break it into seven
practicalities you know to nail it down
to the ground and i do believe that see
one of the things we found we thought
well what predicts whether or not this
works because it really works we dropped
the dropout rate of young men at mohawk
college it's fifty percent it should it
should did yes and it had the biggest
effect on those who were doing the worst
which is not very common for
psychological interventions but one the
only thing we could find
content-wise that predicted how well it
would work was number of words written
and so my sense was well that just was
an index a rough index of how much
thought they put into it and how vividly
and then it would be did they treat
their future self with some love like
genuinely and then did they
differentiate that so it wasn't just an
abstract mountaintop conceptualization
so but let's add one wrinkle that brings
the beauty thing back
because you go back and ask them why
didn't you pay attention to your future
so
before well sometimes people don't think
they could they have no idea that that's
even a possibility that's
i don't deny that yeah but
overwhelmingly people said i don't want
to look at that person because that's me
old and ugly they they're afraid of it
yeah and it's an aesthetic judgment it's
an issue
judgment and what you have to do is get
them to re-form it
but what if that's an old it's a shallow
aesthetic judgment yes that's right
exactly my wife she she she does
portraits and one of the things that's
really interesting about my wife's art
is she will look at she's like goya
although you know
obviously but one of the things i really
found striking about tammy is like she
did a very detailed picture of my
daughter's surgical wound and that's not
an easy thing to look at right because
you don't want to look at that but that
also ties in with the ideas we've been
discussing about the fact that
so in in the story of exodus
when
god tells moses how to stop the
israelites from being bitten by
poisonous snakes he insists that they
have to look at what's poisoning them
and well i think that's the question
is the mystery of the crucifixion right
yeah all these images that we have the
beauty of christ's wounds all these
things which sound so
completely uh pathological yeah to many
people if you can understand them
properly you can understand that that
you have to gaze on that which most
threatens you yeah there's right there's
others and then you say well this
inadequacy of vulnerability that
characterizes old age
there's a terror in that yeah and so
people won't go there right but you what
you do is you replace the shallow
aesthetic
right don't let the appearances
right right distract you right let the
appearances disclose
what if that was an old family member
always look through
and see that those appearances are
that's somebody who's been there right
that you care about someone you love
exactly
and so you beautify them so you love
them and the love and the beauty they
reinforce each other so for me to answer
your question right the the you you're
saying the primacy of love
and i think you ultimately mean a gothic
love right
that and beauty are if you're incapable
of turning the arrow of relevance and
saying
i want that to exist
rather than i want that to exist for me
right
that's what beauty does and that's also
the central move i would argue in love
okay so do we do we want to detour into
the true and the it's beautiful true and
beautiful true and the good and the good
do you have something equally revealing
to say about the good and the true
yeah i do okay well let's let's let's go
there and then we'll continue through
this because i thought that was really
useful well and and and i would like us
if i i would request that we return back
to that whatever this discourse whatever
i i love following the the logos that's
the that that i
i aspire to be like soccer cookies like
a true christian
well that's supposed to be like a two
follower of socrates too right fair
enough
right and but i i'm hoping that in this
in this deal logos if we if we get into
the depths
of the true the good and the beautiful
that we can address my criticism of you
yeah which is i'm making a criticism on
behalf of the of the enlightenment and
cause yes yes which is the fracturing of
the the normativities into three
autonomous spheres yeah and this
argument if it's going to go forward
needs something that would
yeah i see i see exactly what you're
doing you better
yeah yeah that's all right okay so for
me
uh the the the thing i want to say
uh first about about the good
is um there's two readings to make about
about this um and one is and this is
what the enlightenment did we can reduce
and jonathan's already challenged this
but we can reduce the ethical we can
sorry we can reduce the good to the
ethical good so that when we're talking
about goodness we're asking how moral a
person is in the standard modern meeting
right
now
the what
plato
argues is that is actually a derivative
form of goodness
it's kind of an algorithmic form it's
kind of an algorithmic form but so so
here's the this the central
sort of at least i would argue now of
course they're going to be ten thousand
platonis who will disagree with
everything i was saying because plato's
been around so long right but i think i
could make a good case and i think this
lines up with
the best book i've ever read on plato dc
schindler's plato's critique of imperial
reason the best book hands down my whole
life um dc schindler's astonishing
but here's here's a proposal
right
we and you can you can see descartes
wrestling with this in the enlightenment
and sort of failing we need
intelligibility
to be wedded to reality
right right the structures of
intelligibility have to be
not identical to because that's
impossible you try idealism that fails
i'm sorry that was too fast for some
people but i'll just let that go but so
we i we we the map has to correspond to
the terrorists more than correspond it
has to there has to be a conformity
there has to be a contact and a wedding
to them together there can't be a space
between them like there is between map
and territory because as soon as there's
a space there's what guarantees and what
manages the space and at some point this
is this is taylor's point you need a
contact epistemology
right okay right so now there's nothing
you can do
right
that will show me or give me an argument
for why intelligibility shall not should
conform that way to reality because what
you'll do is get locked in right and
this is what plato saw right
but what what plato's basically saying
is there is it's like if i can put it
this way i'll try and put it in a way
that's more
narrative it's like there's a perpetual
promise
that intelligibility will track reality
and that we find that to be
inexhaustibly the case but there's no
argument we can give that will
ultimately explain that because every
argument presupposes it
does that track as i'm i'm not sure why
the last part of that is true although i
agree that it's true so
and i and what's running around in the
back of my head while you're laying that
out is i think well in some sense that's
the problem that evolution solves in a
technical sense so you know let's say a
mosquito lays a million eggs in its
lifetime and so that's a million
mosquitoes whose epistemology better
track ontology but almost none of them
do so they all die yes and so that that
that mapping
i think
because it's philosophically impor
impossible in some sense
i think that
the process of evolution is actually
what solves that and then our cognitive
architecture emerges out of that evolved
base and so it's taken 3.5 billion years
to produce the solutions that we have to
mapping intelligibility onto i totally
agree with you about this i agree
so let me agree and then tell you what i
think it goes deeper yeah okay so uh
just very quickly the the i think
relevance realization basically does
that same thing that evolution does it
has this it's a self-organizing system
in which you would introduce variation
and then selection your your attention
is doing it right now there's a there's
a drive to open up mind wander very and
right and what you're doing is
constantly evolving your fittedness your
optimal gripping
so towards some end which is the
dialogue of the conversation yes yes and
whatever that's embedded in exactly yeah
right yeah so you're doing this
exactly yeah and there's a space of
associations beside what you're doing
but yeah what i'm saying is evolution
actually presupposes an ontology in
which that
will
work right
right right so that's right
okay right okay so that you should have
something to say but we've talked about
we've talked about that before like when
we when we did that uh thing on genesis
and then you talk about how it's this
idea of a psychic projection but the
idea that let's say yuan for example
could imagine that you could psychically
project patterns and and and onto the
world means that it presupposes that
the the same problem like that it means
that those patterns are presupposed in
the manner in which the world exists for
that to even be
right and the historians of science i've
read who
attempt to embed the development of
science in a judeo-christian ethic by
necessity
also you know giving obeisance let's say
to the influence of the enlightenment
say that the
notion that
there was a logos there's an ontological
logos as well as an epistemological
logos was that precondition for the
development of the scientific attitude
and i think that's true yes and i i
think and that's the that's the
cornerstone of ancient epistemology you
don't ask the question how from this the
the workings of my mind do i get to the
ontology you ask the question
well whatever knowledge there is
presupposes intelligibility right and
then i asked i have to ask what must the
world be like such that that
intelligibility reliably exists it's a
very different orientation that's for
sure okay so but let's take it that this
is at least a plausible argument
the promise that intelligibility is
wedded
to reality and there and that we can
realize it
through something like relevance
realization cognitively or biologically
adaptivity through evolution right that
promise is continually made but we can
give no explanation for it because given
what we've just said every attempt to
explain it presupposes it as a
fundamental thing
okay that seems just fine to me the fact
that the promise
is inexhaustibly kept
is the good
is that the good that is referred to in
genesis when god uses the the logos to
derive habitable order out of chaos well
it says it is good is that the same idea
i i hope so i mean uh for me that's what
plato means when he talks about how the
good is even beyond being
because the good makes possible
the intelligibility of reality okay well
that's kind of what i'm trying to also
drive at in this
proposition and that's what i meant but
i hope you took it as a compliment when
i said i think this is a neoplatonic
argument you're making uh you you're
you're you're doing a lot of the similar
moves okay now the thing i have is
right so that's the good
and and then is there a way of and
you mean i think jonathan will have some
important things so that's like the a
priority structure of being before there
are there's actually beings it's like
there's it's there's there's there's a
there's a potential intelligibility even
for the finite in relation to the
infinite exactly because if and and what
you can do is you can reject that
fundamental goodness and i and notice i
can't give you an argument to get you
back into it
but if you reject that fundamental
goodness you will be you will be you and
you you see descartes wrestling with
this because he he tries to
he he gets sort of stuck inside the
cochito right and he's trying and and he
i think therefore i am right and and
and he realizes oh
oh i could be trapped in soul of
citizens and skepticism and what does he
do he says oh no no
there must be a god that guarantees that
the intelligibility the clear and
distinct ideas map onto reality he
realizes he needs something outside of
the argument in order to guarantee that
fundamental goodness that makes
everything else possible but then what
he does is he creates famously a
circular argument for that god and so he
tries to make an argument for it but he
ends up presupposing the very thing he's
trying to prove this is what i mean by
our apprehension of it is is not
something that is produced inferentially
it is an apprehension of a fundament
this fundamental goodness
and i can't i can't give you an argument
or an evidence or evidence for now i
think
i think ethical goodness is dependent on
and reflective of at times exemplary of
that ontological of you'll allow me
goodness and don't you think that that's
the reason why in so many traditions the
infinite is always referred to
negatively like the whole notion of
negative theology or oh that's
interesting see more well the idea that
that
if you want to express that which is
which which is the source of being you
end up having it almost end it empties
itself yes it empties itself of all
characteristics while recognizing that
it is at the same time this the
summation of all character it's like the
good ultimately is that which everything
is culminating to and then
it's a kind of giving away into
something which is always more do you
think that's related to that a prior
acceptance of the of the existence of
the relationship between
intelligence and and being well that
it's
that that this thing that guarantees
that has the is being pointed at too by
these processes i think so i've been
thinking about i've been thinking i
don't know i can take you on this this
experiment that i've talked about this
idea that that identity is chaotic that
identity always kind of empties itself
into more
so
i you always use the example of an
object like you have a it's like you
have a cup and then you have you have a
certain level you have different aspects
of the cup yeah so in order for it to
reach its good all these elements in
order for them to reach its good they
have to kind of they have to give
themselves into something which cannot
be found at the level of their elements
and so so what you end up having is you
have hierarchies of beings that that are
moving towards that identity but as they
reach their highest point they actually
empty themselves into the higher
identity and then you move up and then
you end up with something that is beyond
being ultimately okay so let me try
something to you because that might
start to sew the good and the true and
the beautiful together i've been doing a
lot on uh marrying mario ponte with
plato and john russo and other people
are doing the so i will but here like
that thing you just pointed out so uh
marlo ponti's point is you never you can
never completely see any object so let's
just talk because the number of right or
the number of just even uh perceptual
aspects is which is what castle was
doing right yeah right and then of
course then there's the imaginal aspects
i can also all the functions that are
implicit in this all the use
right and then so one of the things i've
been arguing is is that if you take a
look at plato the idos originally meant
the look of a thing but he didn't mean
the look he meant something like the
aspect and here's here's what the like
so
you have all of these aspects and
they're unfolding inexhaustibly there's
a through but they don't unfold
chaotically there's a coherent through
line that runs through them because
right you get a sense of as you said the
identity but here's the thing that
through line is not itself an aspect
no it can't be because if you you're
making a fundamental it's an a priori
necessity right and it runs through it
but notice how
right first of all that's starting to
get us into
not right a a sense of the goodness
because that's the promise being kept
the true line is the promise being kept
it's also a different notion of truth
this is something i want to talk about
later if we get a chance truth is this
as alathea as disclosure rather than as
correspondence but notice first of all
how that corresponds to beauty and think
about what tammy's doing with the
paintings she's right because she's
she's don't step don't stop at this one
aspect as the appearance but open it up
open up all
and see and fulfill the promise
he asked me even in something horrible
yes
yes and maybe that's dependent on your
willingness to gaze which is the story
of exodus and and the bronze serpent
well and and i i would say the
crucifixion as well that's really
interesting because han talks about
we've lost the ability to linger
with things and that's why we can no
longer you know if chimps if if chimps
are in the jungle and they come across a
decent sized snake they'll stand at a
distance from it but they will gaze at
it for up to 24 hours and they have a
particular cry which which is a snake ra
that's the name of the cry which they
utter that brings other chimps and so
they hate snakes right
innately if you show a rubber snake to a
chimp that's never seen one he'll hit
the ceiling but then he'll look and so
they're out there gazing on the snake
it's part of they're fascinated by it
despite the fact that it's also
simultaneously threatening yes so i i
think that there's increasing evidence
for for something like awe
it's r definitely well that's manifest
and pilot erection and natural okay but
think about what odd does ah is a kind
of love and right of the things aw does
which is really interesting it's one of
the few instances where people reliably
report a sense of the shrinkage of the
self that is nevertheless has a positive
element to it yeah even though they're
terrified yeah they want to they want to
follow it through they want to go into
right well i think that's partly so
imagine this so so imagine aw imagine
pilot erection now so a cat puffs up and
you know that's the hair standing up in
the back of your neck oh it's the same
instinct it is yeah and i i'm doing work
on this with a student of mine right now
and and how we've accepted the pilot
erection into aesthetic yep experience
right okay so imagine this now you're
out you look at the night sky and it's
it's awe-inspiring so there's also a
call to imitate there yeah so you see
the image of mary for example with her
foot on the serpent and her head in the
stars well she's looking at the stars
and she's so that's the cosmic realm
it's the infinite and now she's awe
struck by that vision and then
she
in order to adapt to that vision of the
infinite you have to imitate that which
instills the awe and that's represented
by her foot on the serpent oh that's
cool yes that's for sure that's well you
know there's there's literally hundreds
of renaissance images of that mary head
in the stars foot on the serpent and i
thought i've been thinking through this
aw issue for and it has this interesting
association with beauty but you can
imagine that
when a cat dances sideways and pilot
wrecks it's trying to look larger it's
trying to look as if it can overcome the
predator well that's what odd does to us
is that when we
historically evolutionarily what we did
when we felt awe in the face of a
predator is we
we felt compelled to imitate the
predator so that we could become
ferocious enough to overcome the
predator
and so that's that call to an expanded
being that you would associate for
example with development of the shadow
it's like when you look at something
brutal
you know that really terrifies you it
has to call that capacity for predatory
behavior out of that monstrous capacity
now it should be integrated into the
kind of ethic that we're describing but
you're not good if you're harmless
it's way more than that and that aw in
the face of what's catastrophic is a
call to be
more than the catastrophic thing which
certainly makes you monstrous in a sense
well that's really interesting uh
because because the
you i mean it's also it it also produces
uh sort of increased uh seeking of
others which makes sense because one of
the ways we can make ourselves band
together band together
and then and then that seems to get
exacted into right
i don't have to be big but i can connect
or participate in something right right
and then you get reverence
as opposed to just raw ah what's really
interesting just to supplement your
argument um and this is work i'm doing
with song chimp um
if you like they they have a they have a
device now that will actually cause
people to have chills the chills up and
down their spine you run cold water up
and down in the right way
what you do and what you can do is you
can really enhance people's aesthetic
experience but even more basically you
get people to listen like to the same
passage of music and you put one group
of people in a slightly cooler room they
will have a more powerful aesthetic
experience because it facilitates pilot
erection exactly exactly that's so cool
yeah i was so thrilled about this notion
of pilot erection being associated with
the instinct to imitate you know to put
those two things together it's like well
what do you do in the face of the
predator well one is run away the other
is
become super ordinate to the predator
and then you might say well what's the
worst possible predator which i think is
part of the judeo-christian narrative
because we're trying to
because the snake in the garden is satan
it's like well what's the worst predator
it's not the snake bad as snakes are
it's like a super snake it's a meta
snake it's the sum total of everything
that threatens you and so that calls you
to be more than that whatever that is i
don't know a lot about the biology but
biology but do the do animals experience
this pilot erection in with let's say a
member of their own species that is
bigger or more
dominating sure yes they do sure and we
also have some preliminary and it's
ethnographic so you have to be careful
with it
that they ex they do something that
looks like ah you'll get a monkey you've
got the the snake thing but there's also
a video like of a monkey and it
goes out onto a precipice which is a
little bit dangerous uh-huh to watch the
sun rise and he's not doing anything he
just sits there well you know monkeys
will look longer
if you show them photos of of their
troop they gaze longer at the high
status individuals as well yes and if
they are encountering a high status
individual who could take them out in
some sense but not merely as an
expression of power as the
primatologists insist then they do show
pile erection in response to the threat
from the superior but they're also
fascinated by it and you can imagine
that part of that fascination is the
locking of their attention onto what
they could become right because that's
what at least at least that it interests
me more in the sense of beauty right yes
where is it it is this sense of
shrinking in front of something in the
sense feeling that you're smaller than
that and then this desire to move into
it or contact imitation as a kind of
internalization a kind of being wedding
yourself to someone yeah
it's a form of worship a primary form of
worship right because you
you worship what you
you imitate what you worship they're the
same thing and so okay well that was fun
so shall we move to the next one i think
so i'm getting a sense of how
the true the good and the beautiful
could be potentially integrated
because i think that's a necessary
requirement for this argument and notice
how we are moving outside of we didn't
talk about true we can talk about that
later at that point we're moving outside
of sort of standard ways of talking
about
at least goodness and beauty here and i
think there's similar ways of doing a
truth that could actually get us back to
something
that um yeah well it's nice to put the
biological twist on it too i wanted to
run one thing before we move on which is
that
the way that i tend to think about it in
terms of
um
when we talked about the idea of the
through line yeah you have i think
that's the idos i think that's what the
form is in plato well it isn't it isn't
what aristotle thought it was it isn't
just a specificity right of necessary
and sufficient conditions
would you feel comfortable with the
notion that it's the manner in which the
multiplicity is gathered it's the logos
right and so it actually gathers
multiplicity don't listen to my words
listen to the logos that gathers them
together all things are one right
heraclitus
so then what we would presume
provisionally is that the thing that
unites the true the good the beautiful
is the logos now we shouldn't make the
presumption of knowing that we
understand what that logos is we've got
some hints about what it is but we can't
characterize it entirely is that a
reasonable proposition in your
estimation i think so i i think uh
in in
especially if we're careful to do what
you did before which is
we have
um
we have a dipolar way of invoking the
logos the logos is both
the gathering
all right the through lining if i can
put it that way but it is also
right right
it is also the ontological reality that
affords that happening it's it's the
fact that i can't exhaust it
right no matter how far i push it so
whatever through line i have is at most
um
a signification or a symbol of the fact
that it's inexhaustible
did that make sense what i'm trying to
say what do you know i'm not sure i
understand that that the the through
line is this the significant that
inexhaustible
in the manner in which it points up or
in the manner in which it inexhaustible
like this or an exhaustible
matter in which it's the fact that that
intelligibility between
between representation and actuality
remains regardless of how okay how far
you push it so that would sort of be
like the notion that the universe is
logical logos based essentially but and
that there's that we're not going to run
out of that but it's not going to be
logical in the modern sense right of a
complete system even though you can't
reduce it to an algorithm exactly
exactly so the see this is what i mean
by saying i don't think of the form as
like a standard aristotelian essence at
least how it's been taught yeah to me
which is a set of necessary and
sufficient conditions like the low
likelihood
there's no becoming in that is there
there's just being
well right because becoming implies
transformation of something that's
algorithmic but in a but in a manner
that's not
that doesn't escape from the logos and i
mean i think that's how reality
constitutes itself and that's probably
that's part of the solution to the
scandal of induction it's like no you
can't predict with 100 certainty what's
going to happen next
but
what will happen next despite its
unpredictability like the next note in a
symphony is still predictable exactly
this is what i mean about the good
the reason why hume couldn't deal with
the problem of abduction is it requires
the apprehension of the good which is
the promise that this is not going to be
logical identity but nevertheless it is
going to be inexhaustibly coherent it's
going to remain beautiful and in there
in that sense it's always going to be
something right so it's not
it's not reducible to an algorithm but
that doesn't mean well you said it that
doesn't mean it's not habitable doesn't
mean it's not good it doesn't mean it's
not coherent exactly right right
and your example the music which john
russon uses the musicality of
intelligibility as i think the best way
to think about it yeah i think so too i
i think that's actually i actually think
that's why we like music yes because i
think that music is actually the most
representational art form because for a
variety of reasons first of all we don't
see objects we see patterns and we
interpret some patterns as objects so
patterns are primary then we're looking
for the harmonious interplay of patterns
and then it's not
it's not strictly a causal relationship
because the music is governed by
principles but it's not formally
predictable otherwise it gets boring
exactly right so you see that i think
most particularly i've experienced that
most particularly with box
brandenburg concertos which have this
amazing
continual unfolding that's so logical it
almost appears mathematical and yet it's
unpredictable and you don't know where
it's going to go and it goes there and
you think man that just that's just
right so yeah so you could say that you
could say that about pretty much
everything that exists that is that i
think i like the glass because it's just
easy so so the the idea is that there is
a through line in this glass and but the
through line goes through potentiality
which is indefinite it is i can
encounter a million glasses in my life
and they will all be different that's
like the realm of musical possibly
exactly it's all but they all end up
being predictable to a certain extent
once i
grasp it like when i see the glass i
recognize it but i couldn't have
predicted that this is the glass that
would exist there's a there's a kind of
potentiality which
which is maintained within the identity
of the glass but is not it's
inexhaustible right and when you see
that
you apprehend that and this is scary's
point this is
being struck by beauty you see the tree
and it's somehow it's like every other
tree you've seen and yet it's not
it reminds you of the idols it reminds
you of just what you said and that's
love i think that that's love too like
in love in the sense that i've often
said love is the capacity for unity and
multiplicity to exist
that's what love is right that is that i
i recognize something of you that we
have in common
but i also recognize you're completely
separate from me and they both are
valued those both have to coexist for
love to be real it has to be separation
well to give the devil is due you know i
would say that's the kernel of good that
the diversity types are pushing you know
we need to recognize the utility of
multiplicity it's like fair enough
the the problem with that a problem with
that is well yeah but what's where's the
unity here where's the unity it's all
diversity it can't be all diversity
because then all we do we're in conflict
so
we tend to have a we tend to be the
modern world has tends towards radical
they tend to to want to radical
change unity to uniformity and then have
this kind of crazy
exploded multiplicity whereas the real
this kind of natural relationship
between between otherness is
exactly this
both recognizing what we have in common
and at the same time being kind of
fascinated and attracted to that which
we have well you think about the reason
this conversation works is because we
have grounds for commonality in our
understanding but that would be sterile
without the multiplicity because we
would just run over the same territory
and so you know we hope we aim towards
the same thing enough so that we can
communicate but i wouldn't like it at
all if
you didn't each of you didn't bring
something to bear on the discussion that
i'm incapable of bringing to bear on it
so the
the last thing i want to bring up is of
course i mean people are going to say
i'm jesus smuggling but
there's that's that's the that's the the
reason one of the reasons or where we
can understand that in christianity the
trinity is seen as the infinite is the
image of the infinite that we have is is
a contradictory
possibility of absolute unity and
absolute multiplicity and so we we just
throw those two up at the same time and
we say the infinite is absolutely
multiple and absolutely one and you
cannot
without contradiction and you cannot
totally
that you can't reconcile that completely
because that is ultimately
the it's a problem which fractally
appears everywhere anyways because
everything is always everything in the
world has something in common with
everything else
you know if it's just being itself but
it it also necessarily it must be
different for the difference to the
strong benefits there's good one
argument every object is infinitely
similar and right
which is a
restatement of the problem of perception
itself yes like well you've seen a glass
yes but you haven't seen this glass well
how much difference is there is well
there's an infinite number of
differences as it turns out all right so
this is a this is a this is quite a
switch here and i think this is a
radical uh proposition
that maybe not because once you hear it
you think well yes and then you think
well that's self-evidence like yeah well
not so not so quick here the description
of a structure of values or an ethic
subject to the code of seals that we've
already added
or set of priorities is a narrative so
the description
of a
system of perceptual prioritizations and
actions is a narrative
what do you think the descript that
could be it could also be representation
in image it wouldn't have to be a verbal
it's not a grant a majestic or verbal
description that is what we regard as a
narrative so th this is what i i i
wanted to again challenge you on and it
sort of overlaps with the discussion
we've having about the true and the good
and beautiful because i think there are
three
three different dimensions by which
we organize intelligibility uh
so
there's a narrative
the example i use is video games and and
there's a reason why people are doing
the virtual exodus they're preferring
video games over the real world because
of the dimensions that are found in
video games so one is a narrative and
the narrative they belong to clearly
that's one of the things so no total
agreement that but there's two other
features
that are deeply meaningful right to them
not semantic but meaning in life
meaningful right one gripping a normal
logical order there's a set of rules
that they understand that makes sense of
that world
so that they can move around in that
world with confidence because if they
have a narrative but it doesn't it isn't
undergirded by um
okay is that a reflection in the video
game of the same through line and
and mapping of intelligibility onto
ontology within
but it's a simpler world yes so they can
establish that first exactly so you're
saying
okay so it's a slightly different
argument perhaps because i said well
narrative is a description of an ethic
and you say there's more than
there's more ways that the world needs
to be apprehended than the purely
narrative yes and i think that's fine
but does that bear on the argument that
the description of an ethic
is a narrative no because we also
describe other ways in which we
prioritize
our perceptions in things that aren't
narratives that are nomological that's
what we call a scientific theory the
theory of evolution right is not a it's
not a narrative it's a description of
the way things unfold or let's they say
newton's laws newton's laws are not
narrative in any fashion but do you
think okay so let me push back on that
fair enough fair enough and then you
could say well a set of mathematical
axioms and and the uh operations that
are derived from the axons is also not a
narrative but so and fair enough so then
i would say and this will get us into
discussion about science later
is the intelligibility and the
attraction of those non-narrative
descriptions of the world
dependent on their being
nested inside a narrative but see
and so here's where i'm going to answer
you back i'm going to say they mutually
they reciprocally require each other
just like what we were doing with the
truth okay okay so that that then okay
fine so so is that the same thing as
narrative and the scientific description
mutually requiring each other right but
you can't reduce the one to the uh
either to the uh you can't okay one okay
you can't reduce the normal logical to
the narrative or the narrative to the
nomological that's why that's what i was
trying to get at three dimensions almost
like a cartesian graph with three
dimensions right okay you can't reduce
right well because i suppose if you do
that too you run into the postmodern
trap which is that there's nothing but
the narrative intelligibility there's
nothing but the narrative there has to
yes and there also has to be something
there has to be a space within which we
can compare narratives move between
narratives and learn creatives right and
there has to be something that allows us
to override narrative bias you know the
research on narrative bias it's powerful
it's one of our most powerful bias there
has to be something that can kick us out
of the narrative bias but i think okay
the way that the way that i would phrase
it is
myself is that
the reason why we tend to think or like
even the way that i present it is that
the priority of narrative is because
narrative is the embodied manner in
which we engage with a structural values
that is it's the way that we engage in
structural values and so because because
we
see a dis and usually it has a narrative
that embody pattern is a description of
the embodied pattern
i think that it i think that it because
i don't know if it's a story if you act
it out i don't know if it's a story
until it's a representation of a pattern
of actions because otherwise it's it's
more like a pattern of behavior you know
like so for example imagine you watched
wolves interacting yeah you could say
well it's as if they're following the
following narrative rules
but they're not because they don't have
it's not narrative it's a pattern in
their behavior right but for the same
reason that
it's the through line like for the same
reason that you can't see the glass from
the elements of the glass it doesn't
mean that the glassness like the
identity of the glass has a causal
relationship to its elements it's just
not a cause it's not that a mechanical
caused a relationship it's a the causal
of identity
and so the narrative or let's say the
pattern of behavior is causal from above
you could say
because it's that the way in which you
recognize that the behavior is a pattern
in the first place right okay i want to
push back on you i know you have to yeah
this is one of the areas where we we
kind of don't totally agree but that's
good because
well this is a real mystery this problem
because it is the relationship between
science and the narrative of meaning
it's a relationship between ontology and
epistemology or between description and
value i mean so it's no wonder that this
is causing you know a little bit of
trouble i want to throw in one more
dimension which is right which is
you can also level up in the game
there's a way in there there's a
dimension that's not a narrative it's
it's an act of self-transcendence right
um i call it i thought about this
that you can scale yeah so that has to
be that's quidditch by the way that's
what rolling represented with quidditch
because there's a game and a metagame
if you win the metagame you also win the
game right okay but not vice versa which
is very it's so smart
so that's right you you you do this
jordan you'll just throw these
observations that are like what's even
worse than that
players are chasing is the round chaos
of el camine that contains all the
potential of the world right and it's
also the spirit of mercury like it's
like i don't know how she did that it's
just beyond belief that she managed that
i don't know i really don't
need that yeah it's like if you get if
you
the way to understand it like in terms
of a glass would be like once you grasp
the logos this is the same maximus way
of speaking too once you grasp the logos
then you you are able to you've captured
all the rules and everything else and
once you understand what a glass is then
you don't have to you can recognize
every glass in the entire world it's
like it's such a massive power you've
overcome the entire game through getting
this one thing which is like which is
often imaged as a seed or as a golden
ball or as something sparkling which is
what you represent like in the world but
is ultimately pointing above it
well that's part perhaps that's a uh
reflected in
the insistence that adam is to name all
the animals
right in in the in the story of adam and
eve because that's obviously kept in the
narrative for a reason and it has to do
with the power that
naming and subduing in the sense that
you've described which is the also
simultaneous imposition of a hierarchy
of categorization that goes along with
naming that gives you a grip on the
world
and that that grip is associated with a
moral necessity and requirement in that
story it's for me the nomological
dimension is the naming dimension that's
what science does broadly construed and
that's different from telling a story
naming things is different from telling
a story so all but ultimately this is
where this is where i kind of come back
again
before but
so ultimately because
we are not disembodied beings like this
is so science
this type of nonlogical order
is taken from a position where i am
as i see the nomological order i have to
climb the yes the ladder and so and cli
especially most narratives always have a
sense of this is moses on the mountain
again yes yes but there's also there's
that's why the narrative is always this
like almost all narratives are that it's
it's you notice the difference and once
you you notice the distance and when you
notice the distance then you have to
re-establish a connection with that
with which you're distant because you
don't need an ethic unless you notice
the difference
you just i mean you don't need at least
you don't need an explicit ethic you
don't have to why why not unless you
notice the difference because you don't
have to tell someone how to go
downstairs unless they can't do it
you're going you don't you don't have a
you don't have an explicit set of rules
okay so there has to be no there has to
be an objection there must be a problem
so saint paul says something like okay
the law is written on the human heart
which means that it doesn't mean all the
laws are written
extensively in every detail in the human
heart it's like no
that is in the human heart in that in
that little golden ball in that center
in that place where everything comes
together you have
contain all the potentiality everything
that has the through line is contained
in that but now if you notice the
difference then you have to formulate
that difference and then that becomes
the laws or just the ways of being so i
can say something at first like
when you're driving a car like there's
specific laws and then a problem comes
up it's like oh well well actually
there's a differentiation here which we
have to make or else there's a problem
right right right so we can create the
ethic that's going to just keep getting
more and more detail and more and more
so you start with the law you end up
with like this let's say in jewish
tradition you end up with this huge
compendium of exceptions and like
details and everything sure but
ultimately the idea is that all of that
is ultimately contained in the
something which gathers it all together
into one into this ineffable point that
transcends
but but the space in which all the laws
are being made and written that's not a
narrative space right
let me go after you on that for a minute
the ten commandments is not a statement
because i no i don't think that's true
you think that i think it is a story
that's why christ when christ so he okay
that's a good entry point okay that's a
good answer but it was the story which
reveals the ten commandments right but
okay but there's a lot of those
aren't this aren't i believe that yeah
there is a little bit but i think
they're you're right but why this is why
we say that the ten commandments is
embedded in a story without the story of
the israelites leaving
leaving egypt finding themselves in a
desert of of of nothingness having to
reconnect with the transcendent
that is why the law exists so the
nomological
order
is embedded in
the story you wouldn't have to but the
reversal is also the case go ahead go
ahead if there isn't if god doesn't
offer us the nomological order there's
no point for the exodus in the story
right
right that's okay we could we could
hypothesize that it comes up from the
bottom and down from the top
this is even before that right we're
trying to talk about like i i'm
proposing that the narrative and the
normal logical and whatever we want to
call this self-transcending dimension
are irreducible to each other they're
not neither none of them can exist
independent that's why i'm using the
three dimensions yeah metaphor yeah
right they are interdependent but
they're not they're not reducible
so i'm resisting i would say this okay
autology is is not captured inside
epistemology because
epistemology cannot reach to the full
extent of the multiplicity of ontology
so okay so now why is that relevant to
what you just said
that's part of the irreducibility you're
arguing i think in some sense that
no matter what the story is there's
something that's real that's beyond that
story is that okay okay so so let me put
a couple of twists in that got it
is that okay for you jonathan right now
no i think it's fine okay okay so you
said there's no story in the in the ten
commandments right and jonathan had one
objection i have a different take on
that that that he may appreciate maybe
maybe you too
when the pharisees so the pharisees and
the scribes are always trying to cr trap
christ in the gospels into making a
heretical statement or doing something
that clearly violates the law so they
call them on healing on the sabbath for
example yes and there's like 10 stories
like that where smart people
who run on algorithms try to trap them
and it never works because he does the
thing you described which is he just
refers to a higher order principle or
even three levels up and says like no
yes
but one of the things that happens is
the pharisees come and say
well here's the decalogue which is the
most important law and the trick there
is no matter what he says he says the
others are less important and so now
he's a heretic and
they get to take him away and he says
put god above all else
and love your neighbor as yourself
it's
all of the laws are derived from that
spirit
and that spirit is that spirit is a
story and that story is the logos
and so so that's the move that i don't
like
slow down jordan okay
i get that's the spirit i totally get
that well then the question is what is
the spirit but why is the spirit
necessarily a story
well i don't know why it's necessarily a
story but i know that it's necessarily a
story in that context because the spirit
that christ is referring to that unites
the decalogue
is the logos and the whole biblical
corpus the narrative that stem that
spans the entire biblical corpus is the
account of the elaboration of that
spirit across time and its
embodied incarnation
and that presents itself as a story and
so and i think the reason for that is
that it just
okay so so i mean i get i understand
your point i understand the point that
you're making now and so
i'm actually understanding your point
better than i've ever suggested before
right well you're talking about that
that which transcends the current
narrative and that has to be there
there's no reality so
okay let's
let's leave that for for a moment
i just want to okay one more thing
because i think it's important sorry no
no that's fine i think we're at a key
moment so we are so one of the things
that that we've been discussing and this
has been coming back over and over is
that
okay so let's say that we
understand that there is a certain type
of equivalence and two functions for a
nominological order like a hierarchy
that's presented you know like just a
series of categories which are related
in embedded structure right and i see
science committed to that right okay
and that this also coexists for sure in
scripture
that's what we're seeing it's like it
actually it co-exists together it's like
you have the story of the israelites in
the bible then you have these series of
laws which is actually not just ten it's
a
lot a lot of laws right so you have all
these laws and so but one of the things
that you've said several times is that
you you want to you feel like the
solution to the meaning crisis yes
doesn't need narrative or that narrative
shouldn't be part of the solution and so
i think that if those two are
both have their function let's say why
is it that you want to remove one and
keep the other oh okay that's an
excellent question this is something sam
harris struggles with too but no i'm
dead serious about that i'm good serious
about that so
let me answer this really carefully and
uh tell me we're getting too far afield
from the main discussion okay so i'm
going to depend on both of you yeah my
argument is the nomological order that
one of the problems of the meeting
crisis is the nomological order that we
have is no longer in any way relatable
to or what can be wedded to a narrative
because the nomological order we have
right is that there it it so what used
to bridge between the nomological order
and the narrative order is teleology so
tediology says the nomological order is
ordered but it's ordered in this way and
the teleology has this structure and
then narrative says oh i can glum onto i
can i can conform to a teleological
order because stories are inherently
teleological but they're different from
just a teleology just telling a
teleology isn't a story but stories can
attach to teleology is that why is why
is describing a teleology not a story
because you could describe it
i think that's you could describe the
cop but then the problem is is well can
you describe the top cup in the absence
of a narrative and i mean i think part
of the argument i'm trying to make in
this so this is our key disagreement in
some senses i don't think you can okay
and so well let's be really careful
because we might we might also be
engaged in in semantic drift
so i i'm trying to limit like we can
trivialize what we mean by narrative it
means they need restriction of a series
of events as a narrative okay yeah yeah
no no i don't want to do that i get your
point no no we don't want to we don't
want to widen the words so much that the
argument though but
wait a minute no no i would i would
actually object to that because any
descriptions of events that i can
conceive as being one
is has to have some kind of narrative
structure otherwise we have the other
relationships we have the same problem
of
and and and and combinatorial exposure
if i can recognize that events connect
together that opens up that means that
you would you have to not metaphorically
i actually know i agree with that but
not unfortunately let me challenge it
though fortunately but and i'm not
speaking metaphorically here because if
i'm speaking metaphorically we're just
coughing another thing that means that
music has a narrative
because it has a melody you're saying a
melody is a narrative and that strikes
me as
a very
improper thing to say that okay that's a
tough one man yeah because
then you have to start to wrestle with
well what do you mean by music
because you could say that the the
sequence of the notes in and of itself
may not have a narrative although i'm
not certain of that but you could say
that because
but then the question is
when you're listening to the music and
it has the effect that you regard as
music on you
how much of that effect including the
aesthetic
is a consequence of a narrative so i
would say well when you say music how
sure are you that what you're saying is
that's nothing but the relationship of
the notes to one another i agree that's
a good point because there's no
embodiment in that right right and
there's a sense in which music is
neither subjective or objective right
right like beauty yes yes it has to have
something
that is at least analogous to
narrative because in order for you to
recognize and and it's funny because the
moderns tried to go away from that you
understand modern really tried to break
it but there was in in any traditional
society there are tropes of music which
help you understand when something's
beginning when something's ending and
then you can map them on to narrative
very directly because that's what
happens okay
because if you give me the you say oh
i'm gonna i'm gonna send you a narrative
to mirror to melody then i'll say here's
a logical argument and there's a
progression and a through line from the
premises to the conclusion is that a
narrative mm-hmm
well that's a tough one right because
because the the fact that you selected
out those
those okay
here's something i've been thinking
about i'm going to take a slight detour
but go right back to the point so
i i thought about this more when i was
talking to richard dawkins because i
think dawkins is a good faith player and
i think he believes he's a real
scientist and he believes that the truth
will set you free which scientists have
to believe to be scientists because they
cannot be scientists if they're not
pursuing the truth the truth is sacred
to the doctor absolutely absolutely you
want to admit that but it is okay so so
i was thinking about the scientific
endeavor and i re i thought a lot about
this when i was reading's work on
alchemy because jung attempted to
situate the development of science in
this alchemical fantasy and it's very
interesting piece of work so he believes
that there was this immense motivated
narrative that provided the historical
precondition in the realm of unconscious
fantasy for the flourishing of science
so it's
amazing argument in any case
thinking about that i thought well
there's a set of facts and that's kind
of the argument you're making there's a
set of facts independent of the
narrative and that's kind of the
scientific viewpoint there's a set of
facts independent of the narrative and
even more importantly we should identify
the set of facts that's maximally
independent of any narrative because
why should your facts prevail and we
want a universal set of facts and fine
look what we've got with that but then i
think
wait a second
when you're practically engaged in the
process of science the sort of things
that kuhn tried to lay out is it not the
case that you're always engaged within a
system of practice and perception that's
defined by at least an implicit if then
statement and so i would say
if this is your aim then
that's the set of relevant and true
facts conditional implications well yeah
well so so if you're a medical
researcher it's like well here's
here's what the cancer cell is doing
well what do you mean doing because it's
doing an infinite number of things oh
well if we want to understand the cancer
cells so that we can eradicate cancer
then this is what the cancer cell is
doing now it's also doing something
that's independent of that narrative but
the weird thing about that is that it's
doing such a plethora of things
independent of that narrative that you
drown in the complexity of course so so
then so then we have a problem here
right is that you they have the facts of
the cancer cell which are multiplicitous
then you have the set of relevant facts
which hopefully are still facts but
those aren't derivable without the
narrative that we should save lives that
saving lives is good that we can pay
careful attention to the horrors of
disease in the attempt to ameliorate
suffering
all of that framework seems to be a
precondition for the abstraction of the
relevant facts i agree with everything
you said okay what i disagreed with was
the identity statement you slipped in
which is okay the ethic is a narrative
that's exactly what's in dispute here
the dispute isn't that we don't need
these normative structures i'm not
disputing that at all what i'm what i'm
disputing is that they're all reducible
to the narrative
effort right that there's also a logical
ethic right well that's also why i
wanted to get to the last i mean
actually i think that i'm coming closer
to you than ever because this is
wonderful in the sense that because i i
need to work it out but because i i see
that in like let's say that there is a
clearly a distinction in the story like
in the story there is a story and then
there's the laws and they're related but
they're different and so i need to think
about how they're
why they're related well one of the ways
they have
there's an interesting weirdness there
that's also associated with the
scientific enterprise because one of the
things you're trying to do imagine if
you impose a strict narrative that
there's a very limited set of facts that
make themselves manifest well what you
want to do scientifically is say well
let's abstract out the set of relevant
facts in a manner that's relevant to a
multitude of redemptive narratives
simultaneously okay so let me pick up on
that so let me try and using what we've
just said specify the difference how i
would put it i think what science does
is it picks up on normal logical
relations which are supposed to be as
you say causal invariance for the
universe
right force equals mass times
acceleration we'll forget einstein right
across narratives right right a
narrative is not about causal laws a
narrative is about an irr
irrepeatable causal pathway when i ask
why did napoleon lose at waterloo i
don't give you a law i give you a
narrative i give you a narratives are
this event leads to this event it's a
through line like you said but it's a
through line that explains the specific
occurrence of specific events it's
exactly the opposite of my mind of what
science does science is trying to
explain the universality that is not
captured in the specifics of a specific
causal pathway that's why i can't see
okay so then okay so imagine this
imagine this you have so there's this
notion in the old testament there's a
sequence of stories so it's an
aggregation of stories and there's an
idea that the meta narrative of christ
is implicit in that set of narratives
yes and so then i have this idea well
and jung talked about this as well said
imagine you take any random sample of
narratives comprehensive random sample
of narratives and you attempt to extract
out the common story it's going to be an
image of something like christ you could
even say that that's what christ is in
some sense so and we can argue about
that but
it's a it's it's like saying that the
hero narrative is archetypal it's the
same idea if you have 25 narratives and
you see what makes them interesting
adventure stories it's the hero
archetype so the reason why you can
recognize it as a through line in the
first place is because it has a pattern
but that's my point my point is just
like the through line of all the aspects
is not an aspect the through line of all
the stories is not itself a story yeah
but see i'm i'm not so sure that's that
is definitely what we're arguing about
and i'm not i'm not saying i know this
there may be a distinction between
a story
and the pattern of all stories and maybe
that's something we can think about too
because in my work in maps of meaning i
called
just a narrative a story but the the
story that unites all narratives is a
meta-story it's and piaget caught onto
this too in some sense because
he started to try to find out what kids
regarded as true and then by the end of
his career he said
well what we really want to know if
we're studying truth isn't the nature of
any contingent truths so any
representations within the system
narrative or otherwise but the process
we need to specify the process by which
all truths come to be as the ultimate
truth and then i would say that the meta
narrative that constitutes christ from
the symbolic perspective is the story of
the process by which
what would we say the it's the story
it's certainly the story of the process
by which narratives transform it it's
not exactly a story because it's a
meta-story it's but it's a problem of
it's the problem of this kind of
apophatic move this chaotic reality
which is true also of the nomological
order as well
the origin of the nominological order is
not a nomological order exactly in the
same way that the origin of a narrative
is not a narrative it's not a detailed
narrative per se the pattern patterns
all move into the manner in which they
transcend themselves and ultimately give
up to this diplomatic like this this
negative space or negative reality and i
think the normal logical and the
narrative and what you this
self-transcending dimension they all
converge right now
okay so imagine imagine that's not to
say they're identical no of course
they're not because that's why they
converge right right and i i think if
they were so obviously identical we
wouldn't have a conflict between science
and religion which we apparently have so
so it's an important distinction so
imagine you have this set of narratives
that are particularized and out of that
you
you extract a general pattern and the
pattern is something akin to the process
of adaptation itself which is the
manifestation of the divine word let's
say in its ability to call order out of
chaos it's got this hierarchy of
narratives and there's something at the
pinnacle and so then imagine that you
have a set of corresponding facts and
each specific narrative would give you a
set of proximal facts but there's an
abstraction from the facts that
approximates universal scientific truths
but i would say that maybe they exist in
relationship to the application of that
meta-narrative because isn't it the case
now i don't know i can't figure this out
isn't it the case that we abstract out
commonalities
like force equals mass times
acceleration
because we want to further our
adaptation to the world yeah
simultaneously we're exploring the
intrinsic logos of
ontology but we've already agreed to
some degree that there's a there's a
similitude between that ontology and the
epistemology and so maybe as we abstract
out from scientific truths towards the
universal we
not only must we simultaneously move up
the abstraction level in a narrative
sense jung's point would be we better or
will misuse the nomological to destroy
ourselves wouldn't that also be the case
if we abstracted up the narrative
without also going up the normal logic
well he he he
believed that the the problem with the
first millennia of christianity was that
we did exactly that was that we
emphasized spiritual redemption to such
a degree
try to reduce
redemption itself to the spiritual then
the world was still crying out because
of its
ontological suffering it's like well if
we're all redeemed by the sacrifice of
christ it's like what's with all the
poor and diseased people and that that
call for the unredeemed material was
part of what he saw as the motivational
foundation for the
the the systematic investigation say
that led to the development of medicine
yeah so so there was an insufficiency
there was an insufficiency
maybe it's the insufficiency of getting
lost in epistemology if it's just a
narrative it's just a narrative well
it's not it has to refer to the world
okay so well
that complicates things right because
part of what we're stuck on here to some
degree is
in that ontological realm that's outside
any given narrative there is also a
logos and then the question is is that
ontological logos the nature of the
world itself somehow a narrative and the
christian idea to answer that would be
see well that i don't know because
creation is separated from god
yeah speaking on behalf of christian
yeah but
i think christianity makes the claim
that the logos is ultimately a person
it's not a story yeah yeah that's very
important right
not a story everything culminates into
into into the into the person and
personally literally means originally
means hypostasis that which stands under
yes right yes well it has to be a person
right right well that's why i also said
though that it's the description of a
structured values is a narrative so as
an embodied ideal christ isn't a story
no right but the description of his
embodiment that's a story and the images
are a story and the reason we want the
story is because the story
calls us to the to the ethic that's why
we value the stories that's right i
would like to see the world the way you
see it because you have a whole set of
tools that i don't have and so if you
can tell me a story and i can enter into
your world then that is truly redemptive
because the facts now array themselves
in a slightly different way that might
be very valuable to me if i run into one
of these objects that you described you
know i'm running an algorithm and
something objects i don't know what to
do what would you do tell me what you
did in the similar situation
and so i don't think the story
the story isn't the
yeah god that gets so tricky
the the the christian emphasis certainly
is is that the embodied reality is the
fundamental reality yeah but the story
isn't nothing that's for sure i'm not
saying that i know you're not i know
you're not i'm saying that at all i was
trying to answer jonathan's question
right
and we're running into the difficulty
that i see
whether or not i'm right or wrong
there's a difficulty oh definitely and
that's the difficulty i'm putting my
finger on i'm trying to put my finger on
in the meeting well it's also the
difficulty that i'm trying to address
with this set of propositions it's
definitely a difficulty okay but we got
somewhere we got somewhere in that i
would say i i think it was very valuable
okay so i'm gonna skip to number five
here every set of values is hierarchical
otherwise there's no prioritization i
think we agree on that because we've
already agreed that there has to be a
prioritization and there has to be that
implies a hierarchy so the one thing i
wanted to ask there sorry i seem to be
the the devil's advocate no no right but
it is again
let's go back to embodied living and
this is actually something you see in
narratives and i would also say that
it's something that some of the parables
of jesus point to because parables i
think mcfag is right parables are
narratives that destroy themselves as
narrative structures uh they're kind of
like the way cohen's destroy themselves
as questions um
and so what i want to say is
let's say that there is we we seem to
have like there's the true the good and
the beautiful or we have the narrative
the nomological and i'll call it the
normative in terms of betterment or
something like let's
is it the case
the thing is the hierarchy stable
what i mean by that is you get
narratives you get stories you get works
of art great works of art
in which it looks like they're picking
up on something that is true to our
embodied experiences sometimes we
sacrifice the truth for
the good or the good for the beautiful
or the beautiful for the true like we
seem to be making
we don't seem to have a stable what's on
top we we shift the prioritizations
around there's a lot of great art at
least proposing that so i think it's a
reasonable thing
right well i think that's partly a
consequence of the confusion about what
constitutes the unification so part of
the project i have here is that
i'm i'm beginning to view all the
narratives that are laid out in the
biblical corpus as
their snapshots of the different idea of
what should be at the top they're like
the through line yeah
well they're representations of the
through line we still don't know what
the through line is so to speak right
but there's snapshots so i for example
in in the opening lines of genesis
god so we'll say by definition god is
what is at the top we'll just start with
that and
i'm not going to make an ontological
claim about that just an epistemological
claim god is what's at the top of your
value structure okay so what
what should that be well let's say
that's a mystery okay so the bible is an
attempt to
to
represent that mystery from a variety of
different narrative perspectives and so
i'll give you a couple of examples so
in the
earliest chapter the beginning of
genesis
god is the word
that derives habitable the habitable
order that is good out of chaos and
potential okay so that whatever god is
that's
part of it okay so that's that's
and god is a creative force and then
then
there's the next thing is is
that
god is whatever it is that human beings
are made in the image of
that also provides them with a worth
that transcends the merely material in
some sense because god is outside
creation and if man is made in the image
of god then there's something about man
that's valuable that's outside of the
mirror
materiality okay so that's the next
proposition and then um god is rapidly
that which forbids and allows so that
happens in the garden and then god is
that spirit that you walk with when
you're unself-conscious and not ashamed
so that's
that's the story of adam in the garden
and then in noah god is that which
calls you to batten down the hatches and
prepare
when if you're wise in your generations
you see that chaos is coming and then in
the abrahamic story god is that which
calls you out of the comfort of your
family into adventure and so it's like
click click click click
who knows what the union of all those
things are right because they're they're
quite multiplicitous very but but
but i think they're very sophisticated
and you might say well is that god it's
like well
do you follow the call of de venture do
you take your own intuition seriously
when you think that the flood is coming
the answer to that generally is well you
either follow that or you're in trouble
people you sure know that and is god the
divine word that generates habitable
order the habitable order that is good
out of chaos well do you believe that
truth has that power
so i think
okay so these are all ways of pointing
to that which might unify the disunity
that you see now you can't boil it down
in some way the same way that you boil
down beauty you know it's it's harder to
specify and i think that what the bible
is attempting to do and and i think this
is true of religious writings
of of many sorts is to
what is it it's a characterization of
this it's first of all it's an
insistence that the thing at the top is
a spirit right it's not an idea it's not
even like beauty it's not an abstraction
it's a spirit that can inhabit which is
kind of the incarnation idea so it's
it's a spirit that you can embody or
they can seize and possess you so it's
really something that's living
and
and so it's not merely an abstract idea
and it's not just a normal logical
construct it's something you enact and
it's something in principle you might
think well if you're and this leads to
the next point any hierarchy that is not
unified
produces confusion anxiety anomie
aimlessness and conflict psychological
and social well why well it's not
unified you don't know your priorities
and if it
and if it isn't pointing to something
valuable there's no hope because hope is
to be found in
the movement towards something of value
so okay well sorry that's a lot no no no
but that's helpful
so
let me let me say something and it's not
really a pushback but it's it's sliding
over here and if we can make the
connection then maybe we can come to an
agreement around it so right
adaptivity adaptivity is a thing and
it's really important and it's not an
abstraction define it adaptivity is the
uh that you are fitted to your
environment in a way that allows you
to successfully live long enough to
reproduce right yeah okay okay so that's
kind of an integrated game idea too you
have to live long enough
to propagate
yeah totally
and i'm not here to defend you know
a a gene version or a group selection
yeah yeah that's not that's not what i
wanted yeah okay so
adaptivity and you want to you want to
you know
how does this how does this arise and
one of the things you can do is you can
say here's all these snapshots of
adaptivity and what i can do is i can
try and find
that what what do they all share in
common the capacity to elicit awe
well wait a second just wait wait a
second
so like the the problem is right this
and this is what you see the naturalist
before darwin doing they're trying to
find
the shared perfection yeah and then
darwin breaks the mold he says no no no
no you're making the mistake
there is no
right right right there isn't what there
is right is some things are adaptive
because they're small some are adaptive
because they're large some are fast some
are slow some are hard some are soft
some are unicellular some are
multicellular adaptivity doesn't have
but what he finds is but there's a
universal process that is right that can
explain how all of these different
snapshots emerge but there's also there
is there is a perfection and the
perfection is being itself it's the
continuation of existence okay but what
you just did you've you've played you're
not playing with my analogy though you
you said i can i can meta that and i'm
not denying that you can do that
jonathan i'm trying to use him
okay right i i don't deny that yeah okay
i'm not making that claim i'm just
trying to use this as an analogy and i'm
trying to say well it's a powerful
objection because certainly the
biologists do that they say well there's
no teleology in evolution and and i know
that you object to that because you say
well there has to be because you can't
even there's no unity there in any of
the organisms and there's certainly no
way of perceiving them but they also
have a point which is there's a
nomological unity even though there's no
narrative that's how they argue there is
a universal process that can be
understood scientifically that explains
addictivity explain because if you get
the theory of evolution you say right
all the organisms should be but then but
then you have the problem that
every organism that survives plays out a
pattern which is variation on the
horizon of potentiality and so then you
might say well there is a is there is a
directionality because if the organism
can't vary creatively on the horizon of
potentiality it can't exist or multiply
and so then so so there's a teleology
that
emerges out of the
the necessity for survival and
reproduction and so anyway i would say
so think about sorry i just thought i
got to get this out
the abstractions you generate in your
prefrontal cortex are avatars of the
process of adaptation to the horizon of
the future and so and so the flowering
of the human spirit in its highest sense
is an embodiment of the process by which
the biologists attribute the the
adaptivity it's the process that
utilizes adaptivity and so maybe those
things dovetail well that's what i'm
going to say so there is a narrative
though no no that's what there's what i
want to challenge you you gave me a
model of the logos that i would say is
not narrative except for a trivial
definition of narrative which is
variation and selection and look
instead look let's put it back in the
psychological it's like with humans it's
the willingness to do that though so
it's not just the fact that it can can
happen and does happen and that's partly
what brings in the narrative element is
you do not have to abide by that like
you you that can happen to you you can
you can have this creative variation and
this selection in relationship to
adaptivity let's say to keep it
biological but you can you do not have
to do that
and so i think it's the struggle with
that see that constitutes the narrative
i want to put something on you on that
okay i think there's all kinds of stuff
at the relevance realization doing that
variation and selection that you cannot
exercise authority over because your
authority actually depends on the right
so it's different than the level at
which you have narrative access to your
own being
and look i think that that's related to
jonathan's objection earlier
that the law is inscribed on the human
heart it's like yes i agree but but
let me say if i claim that
human evolution
a material embodiment that strives
towards manifestation of the logos and
then there's an abstraction that's fine
and and that meets in the middle
the fact that you can't control all the
manifestations of your prioritization
structure doesn't mean the logos isn't
built into the a priory systems that
structure that perception for you i'm
not denying that what i'm denying is
that that logos is ultimately operating
as a narrative
i think the lo and look at look at look
at even look at even psychologically
narrative doesn't emerge until a certain
age and it is pre it depends on dia
logos it depends on dialogue it depends
on joint attention it depends on the
ability to take turns in conversation
you have to have all this dialogical
machinery in place before narrative was
possible right well the way i would
object to that fine that's a perfectly
reasonable objection but the problem
with that is is that a lot of that
scaffolded by
quasi-narrative precursors so for
example one of the things you do with a
baby before it can engage in in the
dialogue is
verb mediated semantically is you do a
dance-like play and the spirit of the
logos is and i would say a narrative
spirit is deeply embodied in that
because if that isn't taking place
within the spirit of love and play and
truth then it isn't going to give rise
to the capacity later for the dialogues
so that's kind of the embeddedness in
some sense of the embeddedment
embeddedment
embedding there's the word of the logos
in the material right prior to its
manifestation and i do think in some
sense that's not a story you know
because if you watch a wolf pack
what they're doing isn't a story but if
you describe it it becomes a story yes
right so there is an embodied pattern
that's not a story
but i think we're agreeing now though
okay okay okay well there
i there's a lot of so i guess we go back
to where you said the description of a
structure that's right i said the
description is a story now that doesn't
mean that the description doesn't match
the underlying behavioral pattern you
know i think one of the things i
sort of thought through and maps of
meaning with the moses story is
well why why those laws
so you see in the story it's so bloody
cool before moses goes up to the
mountain
he spends
decades we don't know forever
morning tonight
judging objections so the israelites are
in the desert there's no structure and
they fight with each other all the time
and then they come to moses and say well
we're fighting what do we do about it
and he like judges them and his
father-in-law actually says to him you
have to stop doing this because it is
absolutely exhausting you and it is
until after that that so then you think
what's he doing we're seeing all these
micro narratives right and then he has
to discriminate between them which means
he's turning them into a hierarchy of
value because that's what the
discrimination is
this is what's right in this conflict so
conflict
hierarchy and then he's doing that just
constantly so you can imagine that
within him
this
hierarchy of value is starting to be
built explicitly then he goes up on the
mountain and it's like bang oh
this is
what all our striving is oriented to and
then he comes down the first time it
doesn't map as you said the second time
it maps so the the deliverance of the
message from on high has to map onto
this and some of this
conflict and its agreement would emerge
from biological acceptability because
the people would say oh
i feel as though
that was just it solves the problem and
so the material is in communication then
with the abstraction i think so i think
we're close to agreement i guess
to circle back
i don't i don't sort of deny that i
don't i i'm really not denying that
narrative is a powerful way for
disclosing intelligibility
and the logos right what i'm saying is
is it there's a privileging of it here
that i'm okay so is it okay so is it
important is it important
is the distinction that i just made
between
an embodied pattern
and a narrative enough to
dispense with your because with your
objection or is there more to it well
let me let me let me see
because i think that theories and poems
and music things that i'm saying as
non-narrative can disclose depths of
reality that i can't disclose with a
story
okay so why is it why is it important to
you or necessary to make that
distinction do you think well just out
of curiosity why it's important for me
is that um i'm concerned about uh a
privileging of of narrative i'll use
biblical inappropriate privileging of
narrative we'll border on idolatry right
uh in in that we are well that's kind of
what the post-modernists do so there's
definitely a danger there right if you
over privileged narrative to the point
where the ontology itself does i think
what john is saying is that he's afraid
that if we embody if we embrace a
narrative then the solution to the
meaning crisis won't be universal enough
is that something that's right so that's
a practical implication because
i i would propose to you it's a proposal
okay that
whatever is going to resolve the meaning
crisis has to reintegrate science and
spirituality if it does not do that
right so that's partly also what you're
insisting on is that there is this
domain of scientific knowledge that
should be regarded as in some sense
independent of narrative and that's i'm
still having very much trouble with that
because we still have the problem of
if then right it's like but and i don't
see how we escape escape from that but
but that's where i push on back on the
trivialization if if then constitutes a
narrative no no it doesn't okay if
constitutes a narrative if consciousness
yeah if does because if has to be well
if we want to cure disease if we want to
so jung believed that the spirit of
science grew out of the alchemical
fantasy and so the alchemical fantasy
was we will find in material
the solution to
ill health death
and privation
well yeah ill health death and privation
that's exactly it and so jung's point
was without that
impulse which he regarded as a
compensation to the hyper
spiritualization that christianity
imposed in the world in the first
christian eye on without that fantasy
deeply like deeply embodied manifesting
itself out of embodied behavior and then
out of image we wouldn't have been
because young said well
how do you get someone to look down a
microscope at an amoeba for 10 hours
because like no animal will do that and
his notion was well we had to be gripped
by something of a dream of intense
motivational significance and it was the
dream that redemption could be found in
analysis of the transformations of the
material world right but
like but
the the the motivating the motivating
structure
is not the same thing as the referent of
of what i'm talking about right right
right right right right so i need
narrative to do science but we don't
want to make the genetic fallacy that
that means that everything that science
is referring to is a narrative right
yeah right right right that that'd be
like
that's like saying everything i talk
about i have to speak in english so
reality is made out of it does bring us
to the post-modern conundrum because
they would insist that no all the sets
of all the facts that science derives
are in some simple sense a narrative
right and then that narrative is
associated with the drive to power and
domination and so yeah we do have to be
careful that because we'll fall right
into that trap right so that that that's
what so if you think what a comment no
but i'm sorry
can i say this
i i i i do think that a great manner in
which modern
science got developed does
is i think it is narrative that is there
is
on the one hand the desire to deliver
and but on the other hand the desire to
dominate is there right we've talked
about this before with bacon and yeah
yeah and i don't deny that yeah and so
there is a there is some and so it
doesn't take away the but the same
motivation can drive people in doing
mathematics yeah right the same
motivation can drive people doing music
so we don't want to say that's the
essence of science or music or
mathematics because then we're do we're
removing the important differences
you're afraid we're collapsing
everything yes
but i think yeah i think that it's
mostly about it's about hierarchy in in
the sense of
in the sense that because we are
embodied beings that are living that are
living in the world that are living
lives then all that we do all that we
care about is part of that
reality and so even the nominological
order although i think i i agree with
you now it's definitely not a narrative
right but it it is embedded that's why
jordan uses the
expression embedded in narrative yes it
is that it has to but isn't the reverse
the case narrative depends on the
presupposition that there is an ordered
world in which it can take place right
but that the question is then is that
logos that constitutes the order so to
speak if when you represent that do you
necessarily represent it as a narrative
and this is a deep question i mean i'm
proposing to you that the logos is that
which
allows the narrative order and the
nomological order to unite do what
they're doing that's what i'm saying
right okay but that's fine i but then i
might because it extend does it extend
to the narrative order and to the
underlying ontological order as well the
logos is both in the story and in the
logic that's we think about just even
follow the history of the word logos and
watch how it goes in these two different
directions with good reason
yeah yeah well so okay so
then then the question so you're
objecting that the logos isn't a story
and and that's so strange and it's so
weird because
we could say that what the west is kind
of split on that because in some sense
if you if you think of the development
of the idea of the logos from the greek
and enlightenment side the answer would
be
there there's no
immediate insistence there that it's a
narrative that's right but on the
judeo-christian side there's a
pronounced insistence that it's a
narrative yes and our modern culture is
actually a union of those two right i
just described a couple episodes of the
awakening for the meeting crisis that's
exactly the argument i try to test out
and well and certainly the argument
we're having right now because jonathan
and i in some sense are making a case
for the logos as narrative and embodied
narrative although you also point to the
importance of embodiment i'm not
rejecting i know i know i know well it's
very difficult to differentiate that's
right yes and i do like the idea that
there's a hierarchy of narrative with
the ideal at the top and then a
hierarchy of normal logical description
and that there's a correspondence
between the hierarchies because it does
seem to me that and i i want to puzzle
that out one of the things jung warned
about
he thought
there was an ethos
in the religious story and to some
degree in the alchemical story and then
when the
scientific revolution hit we blew up the
normal logical
in into this massively powerful thing
but our ethic was left in the same
primitive form so now we're in danger
because of that i think i think that's
exactly right i think one of when
i talk about this in terms of
propositional uh tyranny and algorithmic
tyranny right right what we've done is
we've reduced the logos inappropriately
to logic i strongly resist that move too
right so you're okay okay okay well i
get i get your caution because i do
believe that
devolving everything down to the
narrative per se does put us in the
postmodern trap which is what's all
in some sense well it's all narrative
which is kind of what they claimed and
that's a problem because that then you
can dispense with the with the
corrective reality exactly exactly so i
i i use a stereoscopic metaphor i think
of the logos as
like as epitomized in logic as in story
and then i try to look through both to a
depth
that's what i try to think of as the
logo okay sorry tell me that again so
you know how i have the left and right
visual field and then i look through
them to depth perception yeah
here's the logo says logic there's logos
as story and i try to look through them
to the depth behind yeah yeah that's
well that seems on the face of it quite
fine i mean i'm still in a conundrum
because
we already agreed that the selection of
the facts and even the manifestation of
the facts as perceptual objects is
dependent on the imposition of a
hierarchy of value and so that tangles
the damn narrative into it again
but
so but
but there's something that's key to the
idea of parallel hierarchies that i
think is is a conceptual way out of this
that's one of the key moves in
neoplatonism exactly what you're
puzzling over how do these things
what explains their parallel and what
explains beyond the parable parallel
what i was trying to do with the
gyroscopic what what explains their
convergence
okay what if
what if it is something like
let's say you i'm using the word person
but let's use the word uh consciousness
okay right or so that that that so so
it's a maximus has this is why i like z
maximum so much right because say
maximus
he has he has exactly what you're
talking about in terms of this
nominological order yeah this hierarchy
of order
and he has a sense in which the
laboratory for that is man right man
with a capital m
and so
doesn't it doesn't it kind of one of the
solutions to this wouldn't it be the
this relevant realization that you're
talking about but the relative
realization happens
ultimately happens in in consciousness
or something like consciousness or i
mean
i think it happens in intelligence
because we have a lot of relevance
realization going on below consciousness
okay and i've talked about this right
okay i think consciousness is a kind of
intelligence for specific kinds of
problems it'll define normal
that's novel
horizon unpredictable horizon of the
future right right right right so
but let's say
and and i think the issue is yes and and
what i'm here what i'm sort of proposing
is
intelligibility is something like the
way
reality is realizing itself and
relevance realization is intelligence
and the good is the fact that we we
trust
that the
intelligence can track the
intelligibility and by doing that it
puts us in touch with the world that's
what i like is that is that a
presupposition of faith
is that a presupposition of the faith
that was necessary before the
manifestation of a real science
yes the willingness to act i think on
that basis i think if you do not
okay so i'm not gonna i'm not gonna deny
the importance of the judeo-christian
story okay
but i would also say that without
plato's argument about the good as the
ongoing fulfillment of the promise that
intelligibility tracks realness you
can't do science and there's a reason
why the scientific revolution is a
return to plato
galileo rejects aristotle and goes to
plato and says plato is right
mathematics listen to the words
mathematics is the language of reality
there's no math in aristotelian science
for 1200 years
he turns to plato
and that's what brings in the core of
why why is that a turn to plato
particularly it's because plato
like
really in the republic plato makes the
argument that mathema you he had it over
the academy you can't come into the
academy unless you can do mathematics
because until you do mathematics you
can't grasp the kind of intelligibility
needed to get at the deepest realities
of things and science so you thought
that math was the cardinal example of
that yes
and all of our science is dependent on
mathematics and his his attitude towards
myth and narrative is
right
that's heidegger's claim about science
yeah is that myths and narratives are
right that they are indispensable
but they do not have the same degree of
revelation of the promise of the good
okay that math does i'm not saying i'm
agreeing with that isn't that why also
neoplatonism
could never land right he could never
land and become
a a mode of being for a society it's a
it's that's why we've talked about this
before a little bit where
what christianity does is it provides
the body for that which was good of
of the neoplate platonic tradition and
it provides something more to be to be
embodied in a in a communion of love and
a communion of that's participation see
what what you can't get in neoplatonism
and and
and although i'm not a christian i
prefer christian neoplatonism over pagan
neoplatonism because
plato is striving towards the agape and
christianity makes this astonish the two
identity claims
both made by john god is the logos and
god is agape right and and then
that's an identity claim between logos
and agape
right it's not to say they're the same
but it's also the same
and you're going to say the trinity and
i get that right that's fine and i don't
object to that but the point i'm making
is for me that's the crucial move now
here's what i say in response to that
and this is what i mean when i say about
neoplatonism is the interesting that you
would use the word crucial
yeah no i think it is i think it is
because i go back to my point you can't
follow the logos unless agape takes you
out of egocentrism
right right all right that's right yeah
okay but also agape can't unfold to you
unless there's an order and an
intelligibility to it it makes no sense
to say i love something yeah and there's
no intelligibility to it that doesn't
make any sense right yeah okay
now but you see the thing is and and
this is what i what i'm trying to get at
with my idea of the intellectual silk
road right that
right now our culture the hermeneutics
and suspicion we're locked into the
courtroom of debate
i propose that we go back and do what we
had with the silk road which is the
courtyard of discussion neoplatonism has
this terrific ability to enter into
reciprocal reconstruction
with christianity clearly it does it
with islam which is what we're doing
right now yes but it does it with islam
and that's how you get sufism it does it
with science you if you take a look read
john spencer's book the eternal law you
look at what's happening around einstein
and that they're all invoking
neoplatonic or similar ideas to
neoplatonism neoplatonism at with
galileo it's capable of entering into
reciprocal reconstruction with science
with islam with christianity there seems
to be evidence that it can do this with
buddhism taoism that's what thomas plant
is arguing what's happening on the silk
road so
i what you see as a potential defect i
see is a benefit which is it doesn't it
doesn't land because it's designed to
land in many different ways and allow
people okay so that's very much related
to this idea of parallel hierarchy if
you're abstracting out
the set of universal facts then
those facts are useful in relationship
to the higher order narratives that
unite narratives
but that's that's which is i think
that's the claim you just made i i think
so let me let me see so what i'm saying
is that neoplatonism gets gives us a way
to dispose the furniture of thought that
we can come into deep dialogue and it
will allow a sufi and it would allow uh
you know a christian to have deep
discussion they don't have to agree
the silk road wasn't dependent on one
person running the silk road it was
dependent on the fact that all of these
civilizations found a way to deeply talk
to each other why the silk road metaphor
i'm not i'm too historically i know what
the silk road was but why why use that
because the silk road binds the east and
the west together
right it's like the golden thread yes
it's the through line between the
civilizations literally but not just the
physical road there is a philosophical
silk road and thomas plant by the way
who is a christian argues that that was
neoplatonism
so i think i think in one deep sense
neil well there's certainly it certainly
is the case that to some degree if
science is a derivation of neoplatonism
in the way that you described science
has also been a uniting methodology and
system of apprehension because many
different cultures
are willing
with different degrees of ability to
utilize the scientific method i agree
and i would say that's ultimately
exactly for the reasons you just give
gave because science has
has sort of made implicit within itself
many neoplatonic moves
i mean i think it's interesting i i
would say i mean it doesn't bother me so
much in the sense that to the extent
that that which dual plainism presents
as true i don't have that much of a
problem when i read say maximus i don't
even ask myself
you'll play platonism or is this
christianity and i'm not saying you
should yeah
what i'm saying is and when i read a
sufi i don't ask myself that question
either like if i read ibn arabi i would
say yeah he's saying some pretty
powerful true things you know and i can
also recognize to the the place to which
we disagree but he says some definitely
powerful things about the nature of
reality which are the
they think about the imaginal without
ibn robbie you won't get it and and if
you want to turn to some very good
places to
talk about agapic love read suff read
some of the sufi you want right like
i i i i i want to so you're emphasizing
this in large part because or
i don't want to put words in your mouth
but because you also see
see i think think that belief in the
logos is a precondition for dialogue
right yes but you're making a case for
in in some sense it's not a binary
definition of logos it's one that's
informed
perhaps properly
in equal parts from the
tradition of
greece and the it's dipolar yeah yeah
yeah but there's but there's also
there's no reason to assume that there
isn't a deeper unity that
that both are pointing to
i mean we've been acting out that
presupposition in some sense in the west
since since the time of the renaissance
because that was
rome and greece meeting jerusalem in a
real sense rome sorry roman athens say
meeting jerusalem in a real sense but it
was true way before that i mean
one of the precursors to the renaissance
is the the intellectual reality of
constantinople like new platonism was
just
present was was present there the whole
time it just was there and so we know we
don't know much about it because the
city was destroyed and everything got
scattered but the the the let's say the
traditional neoplatonism the man in
which the one of the important matters
in which he reached the west was was
through these these
christian scholars that got chased away
from the city basically because it was
in danger and brought the text and the
the tradition too and then there's
another and then there's the spanish
through the arab work world too there's
sort of multiple times see what i'm
trying to do what i'm proposing is i'm
trying to do i'm trying to do like a
historical thing where i'm trying to
look at all of the ways in which it's
like the glass we can get the
multi-aspectuality of neoplatonism by
seeing all the ways it was able to
reciprocally reconstruct it itself
like reciprocally reconstruct with with
chris with aristotle or with
christianity or with science or with
interest right so you're taking
snapshots of that in some sense in the
same way i'm trying to do that with the
notion of right at the top in the
narrative sense using the biblical
corpus exactly and i'm trying to find
the through line the historical through
line for neoplatonism because i don't
this is maybe where jonathan and i
disagree but i think we do it in at
least a loving manner
well or don't understand each other
fully it's possible it's possible but
what i'm saying what
i guess what i wanted to state is
your metagame
me participating in the dialogue is more
important to me than
continuing the right relationship is
more valuable to me than coming to the
right right definitely okay
definitely wanted to say yeah well
that's a good place to end i think i
mean
we got a long ways through this um
we'll try to figure out perhaps
after we think about this for a good
while what we might do to continue it
because there's a few
propositions here that i think are
relevant i just might share them with
people that we didn't get to
any hierarchy that is unified
is made so by the dominion of a
superordinate principle
so something has to bring everything
together and has to be at the top to
unite
that principle is most effectively what
is common to all that is deemed of
comparative relative value within the
hierarchy so we talked about the
commonality between the good the
beautiful and the true
the common principle of value must
necessarily be elevated to the highest
place in the hierarchy well
that's the abstraction of the good maybe
it wouldn't matter if it was neoplatonic
or the more christian notion of the
logos and then
this is something that you really
influenced me in relationship that
bringing to the highest place is
personal subordination so that's above
me and i serve it imitation i want to
become that faith i believe that that
principle prevails celebration which is
it's worthy of what would you say
it's there's joy in relationship to the
recognition of its superordinate place
adulation a variant of that in worship
which is sort of maybe
a worship is what combines all of those
and so those are propositions which i
would like to unpack with you guys and
then there's something that's more
specifically judeo-christian after that
which i won't get into now because i
think it would be a distraction
so
well that was a that's quite a
conversation i'll come to toronto any
time for this yeah okay okay well i
think we should we should
think about
doing it again well we'll start halfway
through and see if we can get to the end
i think that would be very good yeah
well it's really really see a lot of
what we're doing is
we're differentiating the propositions
right it's like well here's here's the
proposition here's its complexity and
there's some real utility and just
in just seeing the full complexity
walking through it
i mean this is also
right this is also i think a genuine act
of fellowship or even friendship because
the more you do that the more responsive
you can make your argument to people who
want to engage with it of course of
course that's exactly well i mean we're
trying to get to
a diverse range of tools that are
grounded on something as rock solid as
we can manage yeah so yeah
thank you i don't need a hermitage of
suspicion yeah that's right actually
yeah
hey my pleasure man i'm so glad you guys
could come and that we could be together
finally in person and i think the
conversation was a lot more dynamic and
deeper than we would have managed
on june totally yeah i totally agree
with that yeah i totally agree
all right great thanks eric thank you
for all you who are watching and and
listening and more to follow on many
fronts with any luck